では では始めます で この隙のないあなたに不幸は近寄らないという
この我々の生き方についていろいろお話させていただきます
で 内容はどうしようかと考えた途中で
このタイトルを作った方からまた質問状が入ってきて
まあそうすると結構方向が変えてしまわなきゃということで
まあできるだけその件について話したいと思います
この私たちは この瞑想を指導するとき
まあ私立場で言っても
私の場合はこの スローモーション
まずやってみなさいと言うんですよ
で ゆっくり体とかね 動かしてみてくださいと
で かなり出ている反応っていうのはね
そんなゆっくりできませんと
自分たちがかなり早く行動するんだと
結構まあ自慢げに言うんですね
このゆっくり手を上げたり下げたり歩いたりするのも
あまりやりたくない できませんというと
私は感じるなんかすごい自分がものすごい早く活動しているという気持ち
言ってるんではないかなとね
で 今日は駅からね ここまで歩いてきたんですけどね
腹が出ますよ 歩けないね
みんな ちゃんと歩けと言いたいところ
ものすごい まあなんかもう骨が抜けたような感じで
まあ左に寄ったり右に寄ったり
また後ろ向いたり また自分たちが早く歩いてるつもりなんですけど
で 結局時間がかかってしまうんですよ
だからこの歩く距離とかかっている時間って
それはかけてみるとね
かなり労働力なんですけど
まっすぐサッと歩けばね
労働力で計算すると少ないんですけどね
そこでほんのちょっと歩く距離でもあったら
もう何かの乗り物に乗ろうとするし
ちょっとの階段だけでもエスカレーター使おうとエレベーター使おうとするし
で 自分たちが早いと思っちゃうし
で 階段の方が早いんですけどね
エスカレーターより 私なんかはエスカレーターもエスカレーターで私は歩くんだから
みんなにからかわれますけどね
待っていればいいんじゃないかと
私はそれで返って出す返事は
これ 階段っていうのは登るためにあるんだと
あるいは下りるためにあるんだと
階段は勝手に動いてるから
それは私に当てないんだと
ですから 私にとっては階段だから私は登りますと
階段は勝手にすごいゆっくりゆっくり動いてるから気にしません
それでこの結局みんな遅すぎなんですよ
何か仕事をすると かなり時間と労働力っていうのがものすごくかかってしまう
で 本人もものすごい緊張して
まあ神経ビリビリ状態になって
で まあ途方に暮れて もうかなり疲れて
やっと仕事をしまったという
それで仕事終わったらもう結構酒でも飲まないと
あの溜まったストレスはもう消えていかないんですね
だからこの仏教の立場から見てみれば
やっぱり 1週間  2週間すごい苦労して計画を立てて
もうストレス溜まってもハチマキでも巻いてね
もうなんか戦ってるような感じで
一生懸命仕事をして やっと結果を出して
遅いんで それは 遅いんだったらゆっくりやってみなさいと言ったらできませんと言うんですよ
結構瞑想指導を受けた方々だと結構喧嘩になったことがありますからね
あとでこれなかなか思うよういかないんだ
それで私もいろんな手段変えますからね
できませんと言ってほしくないんですよ
スローモーションでやってほしいんです
それで私が指導する前に言うのは
このこれからスローモーションを教えますよと
スローモーションでやってほしいと
これなかなかできませんと
みんなに これできないのはなぜだか何だか知ってますかと
これは完璧なアホだと
まるっきり悪くて 人だけの知恵
知恵がない人にとっては
このゆっくり手を上げたりするのできません
最初から言っておくんです
じゃあ言ってみなさい
できません で まあそうやっていろいろ手段変えてでもこのスローモーションというものを実行してもらいたいんですよ
で それでこの私たちは早く仕事をしているということと
実際に仕事を見てみると早いかという疑問というのはね
出てくるんです それから
このなんで社会が 会社から
学校から 何から何まで我々を責めてますかと
もう早くやりなさいと
仕事とにかく早くやりなさいよ
それは遅いんだからでしょうね
だから私が言わなくたっても
もうみんな決まってることなんです
だからみんなこの このはっきり言わないだけなんです
ですから この 世界でずっとね
とにかく早く勉強することやら
早く仕事をすることやら
何でも早くやることはもう大変いいことで
とにかく早くやることはみんな踏ん張ってます
早くやるために踏ん張ること自体が自分が遅いことなんですよ
社会が我々を責めていることがね
仕事を早くやりなさいよ
怠けるんじゃないよ さっさとやりなさい
ものすごいたくさん仕事をしなさいとか
大量に仕事を出されてやらせるようにね
まあ後ろを戦っても いつでもまあそんな状態でよ
だから正直に何で認めないんですかね
人間というのはものすごいえらい遅いんだと
ですから まあ客観的に見ても
まあ無駄の多い生き方なんですよ
だから物価が高いんです
手に負えない 安くすることできませんから
えらい時間がかかってる
いろいろ新しい品物を開発するときでも
これはもう億単位でお金かかって
もうものすごいバカでかい研究施設やらいろんな施設
もう機械やらいろいろ作って
もうもう何万回も調べて研究して研究して
研究して なんとかどうにかひっかからないと作るんですよ
それは 100円では売れませんね 1
万円とかなんとかなっちゃうんです
1万円の価値がその品物にあるわけでは全くないんです
全くないんだけど これ 100円で売っちゃうと
もうもう 100年間売り続けないと元は戻らないんですね
はい だから ものを作る会社っていうのは
やっぱり 1年  2年で その使ったお金をね
開発に使ったお金は戻ってほしいというふうな計算なんで
1年  2年はまあ長くても5年ですよ
長くても5年です それで元は戻ってこないと
次の開発はできなくなっちゃうんですね
だから この世の中で この物の物価が高いんだから
結果として貧しい人々はどんどん増えるし
それで貧しくない人々も新しいものを買わなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そうするとさらに苦労しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ものすごい徹底的に苦労しなくちゃいけないんで
だから買わなくちゃいけないからお金がない
そのお金もお金じゃいけないし
それで苦労しようと思ったって
もともと遅いんだからね
だからこのカメかカエルかね
もう もう 15 分で 1 キロぐらい走ってほしいと思ったってもね
これちょっと大変ですよ
ですから このカメのスピードで歩いて
10 分で 1 キロ歩いてみるぞと思っちゃうと
もうカメもタクシー拾わないとね
いけないんで だからタクシー拾っちゃうんで
だから値段かかるんですよ
本当はカメはタダで 1 キロ歩くはずなんですけど
だからタクシーのことは一つの無駄で
もうカメがもう 10 分で 1 キロ歩いてみるぞと思ったことで
また法律違反で法則違反で
だからこのみんな遅いということはね
まず理解してもらわないと
みんな遅いということの証拠は
ではスローモーションできるかということなんです
で いろんなやらせてもらいますけど
誰一人も私はだいたい一応やらせて見せますけどね
ゆっくりとスローモーション
こういうふうにしゃべるとできませんだけど
私はしゃべりながらでもやらせて見せますけどね
こういう風にゆっくりとできるかと
で あっちこっちにギサギサない
ない状態で滑らかな滑らかにできるかと
で 今の私にとってみれば早い早い方ですけど
ものすごいゆっくりでもやってみせることはできます
でも仕事をすると 私はもう瞬時に速くやります
スローモーションできるんだからといって
私の仕事を何でもスローということでもないんです
私はかなり怠けてますけど
理由はあまりにも時間残るんです
残る時間でもう怠けちゃうんです
それは置いておいて で
私たちはこのかなり この人間は誰でもね
すごい無駄の多い生き方しています
無駄っていうのは 何も何て言いますか
この生産性はないんだから
だから無駄と言うんですよ
それが人生の楽じゃないんです
自分が必死で仕事をしているんだから
休んでるわけじゃないんだから
その仕事してるんだから
どうしても疲れる その仕事に使った時間
例えば 3時間とすれば
3時間に 2時間が無駄だったならばね
その人は 3時間仕事で苦しんでるんですね
疲れてるんです でも 2時間は無駄ですよ
無駄でした 例えば歩く時は余計に体を振ったりすることは無駄ですよ
それに時間かかります
労働力もかかります だから動物観させてみたら
何一つ無駄のないように行動することはわかるんじゃないですか
部屋に何か虫でも鳥でも入り込んじゃったらね
入ってきたところから出て行こうとしないでしょ
窓をそらむたらそこから出て行こうとするんです
こちらに あんたは後ろから入ってきたんだから
後ろから出て行ってくださいって言ったことにはいかない
全然 だから虫の知識では
外は一番近い距離は俺なんです
そちらにガラスがあって入れも出て出られませんと
そんなのわかりません
ですから  私たちの部屋に突然入り込んでくる鳥やら虫やらね
そういう動物だっても
やっぱり無駄はしないんですよ
この間 この蜘蛛 まあ 1匹じーっと見ていたんだけど
あのなんか上からまあちょっとちょっと降りて
ゆっくり降りてじーっと待ってるんですね
これもう時間かかりますから
見ていられないやと と思って
またちょっと他のところで待とうと
蜘蛛がいないんですね
とにかく で あれ ゆっくりのんびりではなくて
降りてすぐ捕りたいんだけど
あるというので ただ風を計算しているんですね
だから ほんのわずかでも風の向きわかったら
さっともうそこら辺でもう登いて
もうまた上からまた降りてるんですね
いつのことなんですか
この遅い奴と思っちゃいますけど
それにでももう上に行ってるんです
で 次の糸引いてるんです
その時も途中で来て また風の向きを計算して
まだどこにすっかっていう
だからこの無駄がないように
よく頑張ってます だから待つべきところでは待つ
待ってはあかんところは瞬時にやるという
それが無駄のないことなんですよ
例えばもう椅子なんかにペンキ塗って
まあ早く座りましょうと言ったっても
これ無駄でしょうに そうすると
ペンキ塗ったならば まあ乾くまで待たなくちゃいけない
それは無駄ではありませんよ
ペンキ塗って もうできたんだから
もう立派に塗れましたと
では座りましょうと 座るとどれほど無駄かというと
どれほど時間なくなるかというと
自分の服を洗うこと あるいは服を捨てなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
それで服を買うお金やら
もう椅子はまた乗り直さなくちゃいけないし
という大変な無駄になっちゃうんですね
だからこのただ早いっていうことが早いってわけじゃないんです
そういう風に 我々の生き方
全体的な人間の生き方には
いくらか まあ一般的にはいろいろ問題
疑問というのはあります
そこら辺は仏教はどう見るべきかということなんですけど
今日のテーマはね で この今読み上げたね
前読み上げた文章の中でも
この念入りにやることはね
まあ大変いいことやと
それで現代社会ではスピード化と多様化と合理化と効率主義と経費節減という傾向が強まっているんだと
だから この文章を書いている時でも
ちょっと矛盾があるんですね
いわゆる念入りのやり方は素晴らしいことですけど
それやっちゃうと多様化
スピード化はできなくなっちゃうんだと
それは一般常識にみんなそう思ってるんです
念入りに仕事をすると
スピード化は無理と 多様化も無理と
合理化も無理と 効率的にやることも無理ではない
経費削減も節減にもなりません
と思ってますね 一般的にそう思ってるんだから
そういう風に御一緒に設定をです
だから 念入りにして何か仕事をすることは
スピード感の反対 いわゆるゆっくりやりなさいという意味ではありません
念入りにして仕事しなさいというのは
無駄のない しっかりした仕事をしなさいという意味なんですけど
ただ 一つだけずっとやりなさいということでもないんですね
多様性もあります 合理化に反対ですから
念入りに仕事をすることは
合理的に仕事をしないことは念入りとは言えないでしょう
そこでもう念入りに 真剣に
真面目に仕事をしたことで
すごい経費かかりました
いい仕事だったらお金かかりますよという考え方あって
やっぱり経費削減のためにはもうそんなにゆっくりのんびりいい仕事はできません
だからこの思考自体がボチャボチャなんですね
じゃあ安いお金で仕事をするんだったら
もうなんとか大雑把でいい加減でしてするんだするんだと
すごくお金取って仕事をするんだったら
ゆっくりと丁寧にするんだという風に考えてるんですね
どちらでも間違ってますよ
それは正しい仕事のやり方ではありませんね
ですからまあ私から言えば
スピード化っていう言葉はもう成り立たない
人々はもう余計に時間取ってはいけません
物事に過ぎては だからゆっくりということは
途中で他のことをやって仕事をやってないということなんですね
あるいは本をスピードで読む
ゆっくり読むと ゆっくり読むと言っても
読んで他のことを考えて
他のことをして じゃああと 1時間後で読むぞとかね
それでまた本で 2 3ページ読んで
また他のことをやりましょうとか
それで 1ヶ月とかかかりましたと
本を読むために ゆっくり読んだんだよ
それでゆっくり読んだんでしょうかと
それで このスローモーションで教える時は
私はなんでスローモーションで教えますか？という
この論理性 その後ろにある理論を説明するんですよ
物事にはスローと早いっていうものはないんだと
一つ一つのものは自分の時間っていうのは持っているんだと
あんた方はそれわかってないんだ
だから その品物 その現象
その仕事に合う時間に自分が合わせなくちゃいけないんですね
それをわかってないんだから
それで私は簡単な例で説明します
スーパーから大根買ってきて
豆腐買ってくる 一緒に米も買ってくる
それで時間関係考えてくださいと
豆腐はその日で料理しなくちゃいけないんです
だから豆腐はせいぜい 1日2日でもう使い物にならないんです
もう寿命は短いんです
じゃあ買ってきた大根は 2
週間でも 1ヶ月間でも
そのまま置いといたっても食べられます
米は今日 今日全部 この 10キロの米全部炊いて食べなきゃ明日腐るぞってないでしょう
それは 1ヶ月間でも 2ヶ月間でも 3ヶ月間でも 1年でも持てるんですよ
だから 米には米の時間がありまして
腐るまでの 豆腐には豆腐の時間がありますね
だから豆腐は2日で悪くなるんだから
大豆買ってきたらどうでしょうかね
大豆買ってきたら もう平気で 1年ぐらいは持てますよ
虫に食われないならばね
今の大豆は虫食べられないだから食べないんだから大丈夫ですけどね
でもう 1年も持てますね
でも大豆は豆腐にしたら 2
日以内でだいたいみんな2日経ったものを食べたくないでしょうにね
豆腐の場合はその日で食べたりします
だから目の前で我々はもういろんな品物によって時間は変わるんだと
それはどうにもならないことなんです
そこで赤ちゃんが生まれたら
1年間っていうのはものすごい大変でしょ
育てることは で 寝る時間は決まってないし
おっぱい飲んでまた寝て
またいつお腹が空くかわからん
また起きて また泣いて
またおっぱい飲んでまた寝てとか
だから自分が好き勝手な時間で起きたり寝たり起きたり寝たりとかね
でも寝るために母親がそばにいないと起きるために
だからもう 1 年間というのは母親ってあいつは大変なんですね
もう寝る時間もない そこでこの時間の差がわかるでしょ
大人が夜11時とか もう 10時か 12時でも
もうずっと寝て朝起きる
それは大人の時間で 赤ちゃんの時間でもう 30 分寝てもう起きてるんです
またちょっと手足やらちょっとちょっと振ったりして
またもうおっぱい飲みたくなる
それでお腹いっぱい飲ませたんだ
飲み逃したからまたグーグーとね
それで あ もう寝る時間だよって言って
赤ちゃん寝かしてあげようと思っても寝ないでしょうに
じゃあ寝かせてもらおうとかね
そんな簡単には寝てくれません
やっぱり赤ちゃんの体には赤ちゃんの時計があるんですね
それ同じ赤ちゃんがどんどん大きくなってくると
またその時計のスピードっていうのはそれなりに変わっていくんですよ
そこでもう言葉を喋るでしょうね
一応 ３歳まではろくに喋りません
早く喋る人もいますけど
で 全然何も喋れないでいて
突然もう喋り出しちゃうんですね
いきなり いつからかわからないでしょうに
初めはなんかママとかパパとか何とかとか
一言葉一言葉 それもつなげていない
もうやっと言葉を 2つつなげるんですけどね
ただ単語だけちょっと口に出していて
あっという間突然 まあ喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
そんなある日突然日本語を喋れるようになるんだから
じゃあ私たちは大人になってから英語やらね
もう教えられるでしょうに
では そんな現象起きますか？ある日突然
もう英語がペラペラで喋れるんだと
それはないんでしょ ですから
その脳の開発にしたっても
そういう風なこのスピードというものはあるんです
で 私たちはこの二十歳まで 24 までになってくると
かなりの勢いで物事を勉強する
例えば中学校まではものすごいのんびり
あれこれとかなんとかやって
高校生に入った途端 すぐに 2年以内で結構いろんなことがやります
そんなにそれくらいできるんだったら
ある意味時間もったいないんではないか
そういうことではありませんね
そこで自分の経験で言うと
自分が高校生の領域に入ったところで
今までとはかなり量が違うなとわかったんですね
でも何のことなく もうすぐもう頭に入る
それはすごい刺激的になって
それで自分が大学に入ってみたら
なんだもう高校で一年分のものを一時間の授業でもうやっちゃうんですね
一時間の授業で その内容量を見ると
これ一年分の勉強よりもあるということ
そこで自分でも笑っちゃったんだけど
もう大学で授業を四つ
二つ 三つで修了するのを教えを二年もこすこすとよくも苦労してやったんだけど
それで毎日大学なんか毎日っていうことでもないしね
この講義やる時はそれに行っちゃえばよろしいし
だからそうやっていろいろスピードはあるんですね
例えばこの外国語やら違う言語を勉強する場合も
私たちは文化系だから
たくさん言語を勉強しなきゃいけないんですね
それで普通の世界で英語を勉強するなりも何十年もかかりますけど
この文化系の人々がとにかく博士とか取る取る場合は
もうもう四つ五つぐらい言葉を知らないとね
それでいきなりできますかね
研究論文を読むことはね
他の言語で書いてあるもの
これ一ヶ月 二ヶ月でやります
で まあ日本に来てからも
このパーリの一言葉もわからない
日本のね 学生さんたちが入ってきて
私のところに来て これはどういうふうなことをどういうふうに発音しますか？これどういう風になってるんでしょうかとかね
それで基本的なところを私も教えていて
それからまあそれぞれ勉強して
もう三ヶ月とかになってくるともうパーリを読むんですね
それでもっと一年経ってくると
読むどころじゃなくて研究してるんです
ですから このそうやっていろいろスピードっていうのはあるんです
そこで言いたいのは 普通の世界で英語を勉強しようとすると何年もかかる
それでも喋れないという
そこでスピードの問題があるんです
なんでこの文化系言語系の人々が
もうどんな言語でも もう三ヶ月とか見ないでも喋れますかと
私は今忘れちゃったんだけど
もう完璧に あのフランス語を勉強しようとして
もう一言葉も知らない
初めてフランス語も初めて発音と言葉聞いたら
なんだこれ えらい変やと
だってもう二十六ぐらい文字を書いて
たった一つの発音にしちゃいますからね
だから BEUX なんとかでボウと読むんだからね
だから英語に慣れてる私はもう自分だったらそこまで書かなかったらいいじゃないかと
で まあこれ大変やと思っちゃったんだけど
なんかね 授業を一週一回
一回はまあ一ヶ月間になりましたけど
毎日ではなくてね まあ一週一回の授業
一ヶ月後もう自分たちも喋ってるんですよ
フランス語で で 三ヶ月目になると
もうもうみんな教師 教室の生徒たちも先生もなんのことなく
まあガチャガチャガチャガチャまあそういう喋ってるんです
まあたまたまもう単語とか表現とか足らない時に出てきます
それはさっとこれ この場合こう言います
で そこで私は何が言いたいかというと
この大人になってくると
この脳の構成が変わって
物事を入るシステムが変わるんですね
それに合わせて勉強しちゃうと
子供と同じスピードで受け取ることができます
そこで子供たちにフランス語のクラスがあって
そのクラスに私たちも入っちゃうと勉強できないんです
我々のスピードは違うんです
我々大人だから フランス語だったらまずあの
動詞のあれ変化ありますね
だから動詞の種類もたくさんありますね
いきなりそのテキストを持ってきて
動詞はこれぐらい種類があって
こういう風に変化するそう
全部一発でテキスト持ってきて見た方が早いんです
それには子供にはもうかなり時間かかっています
そういう風に この勉強にしたっても
いろんなものにしたっても
もう同じ人間にもいろんなスピードがあります
そこで私たちは年取ってくると
まあ朝起きてちょっと散歩をして
もうなんか朝ごはんちょっと食べて
もうちょっとまあ準備しておると
もう昼ごはんの時間なんです
です ご飯食べて もう庭なんかちょっと手をなんとかして
もうちょっと家に戻ると
もうもう晩御飯の時間
それでもう若者から見れば
このおじいさんがもうご飯食べて寝るだけではないかと
朝ご飯食べて それから昼ご飯食べて
それからもう昼食べて寝ているんかい
笑いたいと思うかもしれませんだけど
そのおじいさんにとってはまあそればいいスピードなんです
ですから 私たちは何やろうとするかというと
この米を炊いてご飯にする
美味しいご飯炊くと その場合は 40分
45分かかります 私たちはそれを 5 分でやろうとしているんですね
だから 5 分でご飯炊くためにはどうすればいいんですか？方法はないんでしょう
それでまあ電気ではできませんし
電気はもっとすごい圧力で
もうすごい電気で だからなんて言いますか
焼き物を焼くあれ 何て言いますか
電気釜とかありますね
だったら米炊いて釜に入れればいいんですから
なせっ 700どうかね
900 800どうか 計算ではいけませんよ
まあまあ せいぜいも 80畳ちょっとの中で米がご飯に変わるでしょうに
それは 40分だから 熱量を計算して 40
まあこれぐらい熱が米に入っちゃうとご飯になりますと言って
釜に入れて じゃあ 1 分で十分やと
なるんですか？ 2 分で十分や
釜まで溶けちゃいますけどね
だからこの法則を変えることはできません
だから心の中でこの自然法則は理解していないんだから
もうアホだから焦るんです
だから私は簡単にアホと言うんですよ
じゃあ無知だから そのものについて焦るんですね
だから一つ一つのものは一つ一つ
まずは現象というんですけど
そのその現象は自分の寿命を持ってます
それはもうどうにもならず
それは法則です 私たちの希望通りに太陽のね
周りは変わってくれません
地球の自転は変わってくれません
今の時期になってくると
早くも日が短くて もうもう暗くなってしまう
夏になってくると七時でも明るい
そんなものは法則だから
こちらでいちいちいろいろ考えたっても
何の意味もないんですね
ですから このスローモーションという単純なことを言うんだけど
その中から物事に いる時間があるんだと
それに悟ってもらいたくて
はい やらせることになります
それで時間だけじゃないんですよ
もう一つは順番 それはものすごいゆっくり
この立たせます 私はすごいスローで立ってみなさい
これは一人にもできませんでした
今まで だからいじめるんだったらいくらでもいじめられる
あなた生まれた時からどれぐらい何回立ったことがありますか？と
そこでスローで立とうというのは立てなくて
立てなくて そこで焦ってさっと立っちゃうんですね
それで私は怒っちゃうのはダメですよ
なんで言うことやらないんですか
そこでこちらの狙いっていうのは
ただ人をいじめじゃなくて
立てない人にとってはどんな仕事もできないんです
もし一回私の話を聞いてきちんとスローで立ったならば
もう大丈夫なんです 頭が入るんです
なぜかというと 自分が座っている座り方によって立ち方の順番が徹底的に決まっているんです
それは変えられません
例えばあぐらをかいて座っている人にとっては
まず上に上の足を伸ばさなくちゃいけない
次に次の足を伸ばさなくちゃいけない
それで その人はまず左足を伸ばしちゃったんだから
正座しているしている人も自分まず左足を伸ばすんだ
伸ばせますかね できないんで
だから正座している人はどのようにスローモーションで立つべきかっていうこともシステム決まってるんです
だからそれわかってるんですから
物事には順番があるんだよと
正座にしてあぐらをかいて座っても
あぐらかき方 またまちまちバラバラでしょうに
それによってまた同じ人でも座り方によって
また立ち方はその度その度変わるんですよ
だから そういう単純なことから
自分に生きる知恵があるかないかと
発見してほしいんですよ
単純なやり方 で この単純なやり方をやらせるのは
それはすごい侮辱ですよ
ある程度で だってもう多数歩く
座るということは一番基本で一番単純で
子供にもできることでしょうに
それやらせて全くダメでしょうと
アホじゃないかと という結果は必ずそれはもう99%
だから仏教の教徒の中で
やっぱり悟ってない人々はみんな愚痴ですよと
何もわかってないんだと
だから大体若い方の男の人々からよく来る反応なんですけど
あれ 今までいろんな立ってはいたんだけど
なんかどう立てばいいかわからなくなったと
なんであんなことやらなかったんですか？と聞いたら
立てようと思ったんだけど
どう立てばいいのかわからなくなっちゃって
こんがらがっちゃって
頭が混乱しましたと だから
それが私は教えたいところなんですね
大の大人なのに どう立てばいいかわからなくなっちゃって
頭もう混乱してしまうと
だからいかがでしょうかね
我の生き方というのは
ものの重要は知らないし
ものの順番知らないし
それでいい仕事できますかね
できるわけじゃないんです
だから無駄の人生になって
もう それでずっと我々は啓発されています
早くやりなさいと だから早くやる前にスローでやってみなさいというのが我々のようです
徹底的にスローでやってください
このスローでやるとすごく知恵を使わないと
それから余計なことを考えるとすぐ早くなってしまうんです
だから考えないでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
だから この知恵を開発するために
それしか方法はないんです
だから知恵がある人にとってはもう何でもできます
知識ある人にとってはそれしかできません
知識と知恵の差はそれなんです
知識ある場合はそれしかできませんと
医者はもうその治療することしかできません
わかりませんと 大工さんはもう建物を作ることしかわかりません
設計図はそれはできません
建築家が設計図を描いて
ミリ単位で 書いてくれる
で ミリ単位でこちらは釘打ちますよと
こちらはライトつけますよと
で 全部書くんだけど だからって建築家に建物作れまでできません
あんたそこまで精密に書くんだったら
こんな釘くらい打ってくれって言ったら打てませんよ
それが知識の世界 自分が習った仕事をしかできませんという
硬くなるんですね 知恵っていうのはそういうことじゃないんです
やれば何でもできる やれば
その差が知識と知恵に必ずあります
ですから 知恵っていうのは
本当は基本的に必ず必要なもの
知識っていうのは まあちょっと一部ほんのちょっとあれば十分です
生きていられます 漁師さんは飛行機の操縦できないんだからって死ぬわけじゃないんです
漁師は魚取ることにしか能がないと思ったって
もうどうってことないんです
飛行機の操縦できる人にはそれしかできません
車の運転もできません
だったら別にどうってことないでしょ
だから全部知る必要はないんですね
知識の世界 一部知っておけばそれで食べていられます
でも その知識は使えないんですね
知恵がないと 必ず何か変なことをする
例えばお医者さんにとってはもう徹底的に知識がある
それだったらもう人を殺しちゃいますよ
他のこと気にしませんから
この病気そのものしか見てないんだから
まあこういうウイルスが入っていたんだからね
これにはこの薬 この薬
この薬しかこのウイルスは死にませんよと言って
もう食べさせたりする
飲まされたりする それでどんな結果になるかと
その人は狙いは この自分が発見した
この人の病気の原因になった
このウイルスをやっつけることだけなんです
厳密に知識的に正しいんだけど
結果としては人は死んでしまっちゃうというかね
そこはなんでそういうことになるかというと
この知識のみだからなんですよ
そちらに知恵も入ってくると
なんか違う結果が出てくるんですよ
ですから この 全ての知識には
人間は 1つ2つだけ持てばいいんです
全ての知識を得ようと思ったって
これは決してできません
無理 でも どんな知恵を持っていたって
どんな知識を持っていたっても
知恵も持ってください
音楽の例で考えても同じことで
音楽は日本で知識的に徹底的に叩き込むんですよ
藝大も同じだそうですね
いろいろ友達がいたんだから
話してみるとね まあうち
ことをやらせて やらせて
やらせてやらせて 結局知識的にしてしまっちゃうんですね
でも それで大学は卒業するかもしれませんだけど
どこかの学校で教えることにすると
自分終わっちゃうんです
芸術家だからいろいろ芸術作品も作って
かなり自由な行動をした方がみんな褒めますけどね
すごい作品作りましたね
音楽も同じで みんなもう音楽は知っていて
楽器も弾けるで もういろいろ動かせるんだけど
いい作品は出てこないです
驚くほど人間はすっと覚えておく
そこがこの知恵の問題なんですね
だから この知恵という土台の上で知識を植えておくと
すごいうまく立派に生きていられます
そこで知恵って何なのかというと
知恵っていうのは何でもないんです
別に 知恵っていうのは余計に焦らないこと
焦っちゃうと あんたもうバカです
わかってないから 例えば炊飯器に米入れて洗ってね
水と一緒に入れてスイッチ入れて
また焦って まだかいまだかいまだかい
焦ると無知でしょうに
そっちを開けたり見たりしたりすると
それでご飯も炊けないでしょうし
だからそういう例で この単純な例っていうのはすごく大事なんです
だからもう大体話を聞いてみると
すごい高価なかっこいい例えや例え必要なんで
私はそれは言いたくないんです
すごい単純な例で全て解決できます
ですから 炊飯器に米といで水と一緒に入れてスイッチ入れた人が焦っちゃうと
その人は無知でしょうに
いい加減にすればいいけど
もうそこは置いといてね
自動的にスイッチはもう上がりますからね
もう 40 分かかりますからね
だから置いといて他のことをすればいいんでしょう
だから我々は仕事中  1 日中何かに焦ると覚えてほしいんですが
知らないんです それそれ
そちらに無知がある もうテレビドラマなんかでは見えますけど
まあまあ ドラマの世界ではね
まあ病院といえば外科手術室しかないんですね
学校で言えば英語の教室しかないという
まあドラマは決まってますからね
もう NHK のドラマでもね
どちらで そこでもう誰かがもうもうもう病気になっても
病院で行った途端 もう手術ということで
まあそれでこの他の人々はもうイライライライラ待っていると
そんなこと実際にあるかどうかはわかりませんですが
自分の親戚 誰かがね 手術室に
まあもうもうシアターという言うんですけどね
まあ英語だったらね オペレーションシアター持っていったら
みんな外でイライライライラ立ち歩きながら
座りながら また緊張しながら待ってますかね
自分の国だったら追い出すんです
あんた方はここから入るな
出てきて 顔も合わせてくれない
まあ廊下でなんか見ること
待っていればできますけどね
それでも入っても もういろいろいろいろいろいろ
もう通っていかなくちゃいけないんだから
私もこの前で行った中まで行ってみたんだけどね
かなり壁からもうドアからドアからドアなかなか長い長い長いかなきゃいけないんです
で それでこの 手術室の前でイライラして
緊張して ビクビクして怯えながら待つということが
もう無知な世界なんですよ
それで私が言ったのは
そのまま持っていったならば
もうまたもう出てきたって
もう意識がないでしょうしね
喋れないでしょうしね
そばにじーっといたってもね
もう何の意味もないしね
いったん喫茶店ぐらいに行って
コーヒーぐらい飲んで
その時間計算して意識戻るまで
まあ意識戻るまではそばにいてあげようとかね
目を開けると あ 自分の親戚がね
お母さんやらおじいさんからみんな周りにいるんだろうと言ったら
本人が気分不良でしょうと
というぐらい考えて じゃあもう 1時間半もあるんだからね
まあどこか行ってご飯でも食べようかどうかね
そこら辺に展示会あるんで
じゃああれ見ようとかね
どうしてもいるんだったらね
そうやって展示会に行って
それを見てもう何か遊ぶところだったら
そちらに行ってちょっと遊んで
またちょうど時間計算して
患者さんがもう麻酔がもう消えちゃって
目が覚めて周りを見ようとすると
ちょっと前に行って待っていればいいんです
それでも だからそうするとみんな反応するんで
そんなことできるかと
自分の大事なね すごい親しい親戚がね
息子かもしれません 子供かもしれません
親かもしれませんね こんな大変なことになって
そんなに落ち着いてね
じゃあ落ち着いてニコニコとしていられないんだったら
私が言うのはでは一生懸命心配しなさい
一生懸命焦ってください
一生懸命勉強しなさい
あなた何やってるの？それで何とかなるんでしょうか
こちらの完治する人はイライライラあっち行ったりこっち行ったり
こっち行ったり タバコの人だったらもうぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃタバコ吸ったりとかね
座ったり また立ったり
またドアの方をじっと見たりとかね
そんなこと全て無駄でしょうに
そうすると手術を受けた患者よりこの人は疲れてヘタヘタなんですね
それで完治する仕事はできなくなるんですよ
だって一旦意識が戻ったら
もしかすると親しい誰かが徹夜してそばにいてあげた方が
本人が精神的にすごくリラックスするしね
そういうことはもう必要かもしれません
徹夜しそばにいても まあ合理的には意味がないんだけど
そんなに全部合理でいくわけじゃないんだから
まあそばに行きましょうと
徹夜して まあそういうことできなくなるでしょうに
だから余計にもうイラだてしたり
いらだったり ビクビクしたり
緊張したり 焦ったりすること自体が無知ということの正真正銘なんです
それで 誰かが何が起きても焦らないならば
緊張しないならば 落ち着いているならば
それは究極的な智慧の人なんです
だから この仏教の悟りの行人っていうのは
何が起きたってても全然もうビクともしません
落ち着いていられます
なぜかというと 知っているから
法ですから だから人が死んだっても
悟った人は泣きません
失礼な人やと思ったら
それは勘違い 死んだ それでは別に焦ってどうなるんですかね？死んでもあれば泣いてどうするんですかね
悩んで悩んでどうするんですかね
何かいい結果でもありますかね
だから人は死ぬ もう避けられなかったと
例えば突然死んだとします
事故で死んだとします
事件に巻き込まれて死んだりします
その時でも泣いたり 怒りでも燃えたりとかね
するのは真理知らないだからなんです
真理知ってる人は まあそれもあり得ることで
自分にとってはもう何もすることはできなかったし
外国に行って何か事故に巻き込まれて死んじゃって
こちらに母親がどうするんですかね
それだったら ものすごく冷静にもう自分の子供の死を
無常 まあなんていいます
認める あの なんとか船でね
亡くなってるから とにかくもうなんとかもう発見してほしいなって
だから発見してもらってどうなるんでしょうかね
ですから まあそれは普通智慧のない人々はやっぱりもう何か遺体でも何かを発見してほしいし
それでものすごいお金がかかって発見したってても
すぐその場でもうもう火葬しなきゃ
もう まあどんな人かとも
一応それなりに調べて
何々ですということにして
すぐ火葬しちゃうでしょうね
まあですから この悟りの世界っていうのは
智慧の世界っていうのは
何が起きても焦れない世界なんです
だから焦ること自体がもう我々は無知であるということの証拠なんです
ですから どんな品物にもどんな現象にも時間があると
それはもう理解するんです
それは大変なことですよ
簡単じゃないんです 同じ人間ですたっても時間がかかるんですよ
いい例 子供にご飯を食べさせるとどれぐらい時間かかりますかね
すごい時間かかるでしょう
では 大人ほど食べてますかね
大人ほどようは食べてないんです
なのにかなり時間かかります
それで決めつけられますかね
この何々ちゃんには 昼ご飯食べるためにはもう 30 分かかりますよと
決められませんでしょ
もう同じ人間がどんどん時間経っていくこと
あの時間は変わっていくんです
だから時間を知るということはそういうことなんであって
何か本に書いてもらうものではありません
そこで 例えば私に聞いたでも
あなたはご飯食べたのにどれぐらい時間かかるかと
それもやっぱりそのその状況によって
もうかかる時間っていうのは
変わるんです いくら私が焦って 1 分でご飯を食べようと思っても
まあ年取ってきて歯も弱くなってくると
これはもう 1 分で無理なんですね
今も 1 分では食べられる
1 分では理解できませんだけど
随分早く食べられますけど
今これももう口やら体は動いてますからね
でも年取っているんだから
私の場合 内臓は年取ってます
ちゃんと 表面だけは年わかりません
だから今はそんな硬いものなんか入っちゃうと
もう消化してくれないんですよ
だから 胃が受け入れられるスピードっていうのは自動的に成り立っちゃう
それは変な頭使って知識使ってさっさと食べちゃうと後から大変なんです
後から気持ち悪くて だるくて
まあ消化できなくて の大変なことになるんです
そこでもし私が胃の寿命を知っていて
胃のスピードを知っていて
消化のスピードを知っていて
それに食べるスピードを合わせると
ということは あの消化には 15 分かかるならば
まあそれなりに噛めばよろしいし
消化にはかなり時間がかかるんだったら
ゆっくり噛んで口の中でもいくらか消化させてあげて食べないと
健康的に健康を維持することは無理なわけですね
だから時間といったっても
これまた難しくて この時計で計算することはできません
それで納豆なんかはね
みんな早く食べますね
早く腐りますよと言ってね
なんかなんかわかりませんだけど
私は納豆ってのはもともと腐ってるんだから全く平気やと
あの冷蔵庫なんかに入れる必要もないです
外置いといたって もうとは思ってるんですけどね
それで納豆は早く悪くなるんだぞと思ったって
その納豆にもまたいろいろ
種類がありますね あの砂糖を入れたりなんとか言ったりとかね
そういう風にこの現象を変えると
寿命がまた変わるんですよ
同じもので だから豆腐はすぐ悪くなっちゃうでしょ
豆腐の水を全部ゆっくりとじわじわと取ってあげて
硬くして干してみてください
1 年でも持ちます 高野豆腐の感じでね
さっと凍らせてね 水を取り出しちゃえば別にもう持てますね
だから高野豆腐と豆腐っていうのは別な現象なんです
同一なものじゃないんです
ですから時間理解しようと思ったっても
結構観察する能力がないと出てこないで
どこかであの  １年間  １年じゃない
十 年間ぐらい あの 置いておいた豆腐やというふうなものを食べ
あの 砕いて食べたことがあるんですね
年間  年間とか そんな豆腐置いておけますかと
その家で何かの方法がありまして
豆腐をあの方法でプロセッシングするんですね
味噌かなんとかに入れてるんだけど
入れて まあいくらか ちょっと力入れて入れといて
ずっとそのまま何年も置いとく
それで何か貴重とか 何かすごいこのチーズみたいですけどね
まあ見た目はもう食感もチーズみたいな食感で
味はまあ豆腐でもないんですけど
まあ味はその味でね 私は不思議に思ったのは
これぐらい時間経ったんでしょうかって
その人がね それをもうまあ
わざわざこの機会で持ってきたんだと
これはもうずっと前から家にあったもので
すぐは潰れませんよと
だからこの現象変わると
寿命というものはそのように変わってしまうんですね
そこでもう私たちも 例えば何か勉強するためには １時間必要やといっても
いつでも １時間というわけではないんです
それぐらいの仕事だったら 1時間で 1時間でできそうと思っても
やっぱりその体の調子やいろんな原因によってその時間は変わったりしますね
だから この私は言っている
この時間というものさえも知識に関係ないものなんです
知識で計算できるものじゃないんです
そこでこの スローモーションという
一つの行動で それはちゃんとやれば
その能力つくんです ものに順番がある
ものには時間がある それで順番についてちょっともう少しお話ししますが
このプロって誰ですかね
プロという人がいますね
世の中に あの人々は何者ですかね
すごい頭がいいと 生まれつきなんか天才的な何かというプロっていうのは
そのものの順番を知っているんです
それでプロになります
だからプロもいろいろね
いろんな分野でしょうし
で 何かのプロやというと
その順番 例えばゴルフのプロやとプロゴルファーというのはゴルフは知ってるってことなんです
ですから このあれ なんて言いますか
クラブ だからクラブはどんなクラブ選びますかと
クラブの重さはどうですかと
振りはどうですかと それで振り-どういうふうに立てばいいんでしょうかと
それは一つ一つ順番ちゃんと知ってるんです
だからプロでない人は
このクラブで打った方が早く飛びます
もう遠く飛びますよと言って飛ばすかもしれません
同じ位置でプロがもっと飛ばないクラブを選んで
それほど高い距離ではないところに打つ可能性あります
なぜならプロだから ゴルフ場のことはよく知っている
それでホールにボールを入れるためには
もう一番なんて言いますか
打つ数が少ない方が勝ちだから
まあそこは遠く行っちゃうと受けないんだよ
ここを行って 次にこちらに行って
こういう人はまあまあ変だよとわかってるんです
だから順番知らない人はもうもうプラスの方向へたくさん飛びますけど
で ゴルファーはマイナスいく形で止まっちゃうんです
だからプロっていうのは順番知るということ
プロの中の抜群のプロっていうのは
そのに足すほど智慧もあります
だから知識だけでもプロにはなれます
医者っていうのはそれまた順番知ってるんですよ
順番ちゃんと知ってるんだから
その順番でやれば手術でも何でもできるんです
だから訓練する 練習するということで
そういうものの順番をきちんと忘れないようにまあする
それでプロというんです
だからものの順番というのは大変大事なこと
世の中で全てのものは順番で起きるんです
一つの順番は変えることはありません
種があって 芽が出て どんどんちょっと伸びて
葉っぱが出て それからある年になったら花が咲いて実ると
それは逆さまにすることはできません
ですから どのものには順番があると
順番があるってことを知らない人が焦ってしまう
で 昔言ってるんだけど
ちっちゃな子どもたちと一緒にこのなんとか花の種でも撒きましょうと
すぐ芽が出て花が咲きますよと言ったんですよ
この子どもたちは毎日来て
もったなくて こう 種を
知らべるんです それで 1つもなかった
芽が出なかったんです
笑っちゃいますけど やっぱり子どもはそんなもんだからね
ものの順番知りません
知りたくてたまらないんですよ
もう芽が出ているんですか？出ているんですか？とかね
だから自分の時間っていうのは早いんだから
家に行って またもう早くこれを思い出して帰ってくるんです
じゃあまた見てみよう
だから それでそういう出来事を忘れないように理解だから
やっぱりものの順番を知らないんだから
子どもたちはそんなことをする
それで失敗になって いい結果ができる
ものの順番をわかる大人がもう種まいて
水をあげて それでも放っておくんです
もうタイミングによってね
3日かかる  4日かかるとかね 1
週間かかるとかね ありますし
1ヶ月なんかかかる種もあるしね
向こう何かの植物はありますけど
種を植えて 1年も経たないと
芽が出る えらい頑固な種なんですけど
だから必ずも土に植えて水をあげて
それから 1年経ったところで
芽が出てくるんです そんなことを子どもと一緒にやっちゃうと
なんかうまく結果にならないんですね
だから順番知ってる大人は全然何のこともなく
農家に適当なところに植えておいて
それでまあ 1年までは出ていると
一旦まあ芽が出て葉っぱが出たら
すぐすぐ見てくるうちに成長しますけども
最初はもうそれぐらいのんびりなんです
で そういうふうなことで
このものの順番知る ものの順番知る人が焦りはない
無駄もしない 失敗もしない
ですから我々は失敗する
いい加減に物事をする
手抜きをしたりするということは
もうものの順番も知りませんし
時間ということも知らない
じゃあではなんでこの 2つないかというと
観察はしない 見ようとしない
聞こうとしない ボケています
なんで子供はものすごい早く頭が成長するんでしょうかね
で 観察するんです すごく観察する
だから小さな子供と一緒にどこかへ行こうと思ったら
なかなか行けない 時間かかります
だからだって ずっとあるものを全部一つ一つ観察していくんだから
坂に向こうんだり 何か拾ってみたり
これ何？と聞いたり それで
これはこういうことだ
それからなんでこうなってるんでしょうか？とも聞いたりとかね
それで母親がそんなことじゃなくても
早く駅まで行きましょうということなんですけど
それで母親はイライラする
そこでイライラがなぜ生まれるかというと
子供の世界の子供の順番というものがわかってないんだから
わかっちゃうとどうすればいいかということはね
大人の時間に合わせるか
で 子供の時間に合わせるかということを
それはその場で出てきますからね
どうしても子供の時間に合わせる必要はできませんと
例えば 子供をどこか病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけないとかだったら
じゃあ抱っこしてあげようと
なんとかしてヘラサと持って行けば
それで問題解決するでしょうし
この子は一生でもそういうんだから
本当にもう時間間に合わないとか言ってイライラする必要ないんです
で ですから 観察するということが次に大事なポイントになってくるんですね
ものは観察しましょう
目があるんだから見ましょう
耳があるんだから聞きましょう
鼻があるんだから嗅いでみましょう
舌があるんだから味わってみましょう
体あるんだから触ってみましょう
その観察すると その順番も全部わかってきます
ですから 人間が観察する能力っていうのは
小さな時はあるんだから
みるみるうちにいくらか生きていられるぐらいは知識得られるし
能力得られるし それから我々は観察することを忘れちゃうんです
ボケちゃうんです それから人生は大変なんです
失敗が多い 無駄が多い
仕事も大変 ストレス溜まる
どうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
それでまあ 大人の世界というかね
もう自殺はあるわ もういろんなものあるでしょう
他殺はあるわ 喧嘩があるし
いろいろトラブル 苦しみ
悲しみが生まれてきた
それ全てこの観察する能力をもう忘れちゃったんだから
観察する仕事を忘れちゃったんだから
なんです だから一生観察する仕事だけは忘れてはいけませんと
お釈迦様は言う 観察 オブザーブ
インスペクション 見る聞くことだけは忘れるなよ
すべて生まれて初めてのことやと
一つ二度と観察できません
みんな同じやと思っているのは勘違いです
そのものは観察できるのはその一回限り
だから子供の観察能力を考えたらすごく面白かったのは
今日は朝のお寺でお寺でちょっと法要みたいなものがあって参加しましたけど
小さな子供たちはお寺にもうたくさん来ていて
遊んでいて で 何人かの子供たちの手にも石があったんですね
小石とかね で 私はもういきなりもうくだらないことばっかり考えるんだから
この子供たちは  2 3回来たら寺には石が 1個もなくなっちゃうんじゃないかと
でもまあなぜか 何かというと
子供たちを見たら この綺麗な石を
小さな小石をね ずっと拭いてますよ
お寺ですから そこでこれは面白いんですよ
この石の形や色 だからその子供はそれを拾って
いいものを見つけたっていう感じで
もうそれで大事に持ってるんですね
そういう子供たちがもし 40人ぐらい来ちゃったら
もう石を拾って持っていくんだからね
まあそこをそういうことをイメージして楽しかったんだけどね
この子供たちはあまり今日はそれほど少ないんだから大丈夫やと
たくさん来てたらもう全部石持って行くんじゃ
では それどういうことかというと
子供が拭いている小さな石を観察する
我々大人が何のことなく平気で流れると
小石が吹いていたということさえも
もしかするとわからないかもしれません
だから なんでそれを忘れるんでしょうか？だからすごい面白く生きてられますよ
観察するっていうことは
ものすごく面白くなってくるのです
それは禅寺でしたけど
まあ帰ってかどうかわからず泊まってて
灯籠は小さな そんなに豪華な灯籠ではなくて
普通の灯籠がたくさん両側もあったし
それでローマ字の名前が見えたんです
ローマ字だから必ず外国人だ
それで誰かなと じゃあミャンマーの 3人が寄付していて
ミャンマー人も来るお寺だなと
また他の外国人来るんでしょうかね
このお寺に と また私は他の灯籠を見たら
またいろいろカタカナ名前やらまたローマ字名前やら色々あって
で それすぐ知りたくなったのは
この灯籠の何本ぐらいミャンマー人が寄付しているか知らなかったんだけど
またご飯食べていたんだから
そこまで行って観察するぐらい子供ではないんだからね
そこまではやらなくてもいいっていうところで
ちょっと見たところで 2本見えたんですね
ミャンマー人が寄付している
それでもこのブルマーと書いているんだからかなり前でしょう
だから観察する そういうこと
ちらっと目に入っただけのことなんですけど
でお寺作った時とかね
まあ今日なんて なんかなんですか
言葉を忘れたらいいと
その灯籠とかね それは最初に作るもんだから
まあそれはそれで結構前
ブラマーと英語でミャンマー大使使っていた時代で作ったことであることも
まあその瞬時にわかるでしょうし
今はミャンマーと言ってますからね
だからそれに別に時間かかるわけでもなんでもない
ちょっと見てすぐ まあそれで終わったということでね
だから観察するっていう能力があると面白いんですね
で それに続いて私に出てきた急ぎの考え方というのは
みんなタイ国の中国人もみんないろいろ参加したといういろいろ形式がありますから
みんな仲良く入って まあ拝むお寺だなと
で その観察能力ない人はだから観音寺だからなんとかご利益をおねだりしましょうとか
そればっかり考えて 観音様のバカでかい仏像ばっかり見て
それ上がって線香上げて
あれこれこれこれと願ってもう帰ってくると
その人とと人生は苦しいんですよ
何も観察能力もないしね
でおねだりしたものをもらわなかったらまた腹が立ったりもするしね
だからって観音様に怒ったらこれ罰が当たるんだから
これもできないし もう大変なんですね
だから人間というのは
死ぬまで観察能力がないと
人生は不幸で苦しいんです
死ぬ時は病院に運ばれた時でも
また別な環境だから その経験も二度とできませんだから
それは思い存分観察した方がいいんです
だから人生にはこの時間というのは流れていくんだから
二度と一つも起こり起こりません
生まれて初めて 生まれて初めてということは
子供にとっては最高に楽しいなのに
なんで我々に楽しくないんです？生きることは
だから無知だからなんです
我々にとっても すべてのものは生まれて初めてなんです
だから とんでもない無知の人々なんです
こんなに楽しいなのに
面白いなのに 楽しいというよりもね
楽しくなくても面白いことは確かに面白いんです
例えば突然病気になっても
もう倒れちゃったって
それは別に楽しいわけじゃないんですよ
大変だから でも面白いんです
観察すると すごく面白いんです
時々ちょっと足とかどこかちょっと怪我したら
ちょっと捻挫したとかなんとかあるでしょう
こんなちょっとなことでしょ
でも見てください それから歩く時はね
1歩歩くのが大変な大仕事
だからそれは自分にとっては痛いんだけど
それを観察すれば なんだ
普通だったらさっさと歩くんだけど
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっと変わっただけで
まあ歩くのが大変だと
そこでみんな変な歩き方するでしょ
あれで別に痛いところは守ってるつもりなんですけど
守ってないんです あと
変なこの痛い足はなんか変な置き方で押して歩いて歩いちゃい悪いんですよ
痛くても ただしく足を踏んだ方が治るんです
早く でも私はこの 何て言いますか
なんかリンピンってご自分ですけど
こういうですね そういう歩き方で歩いちゃうんですね
やめなさいと言いたいんだけど
でもだからそれ観察したらそうわかりますから
だからまあ 結構面白いんじゃないんですか
結局 うん ですから この我々にはもう残念なことに観察する能力っていうことはなくなっちゃったんです
それでヴィパッサナーとという修行法を教えているんです
ヴィパッサナーというのは観察するという単純な解釈なんですよ
観察してみなさいと すぐわかりますよ
それが修行やと思って
ものすごくなんかえらい苦しいことをやっているような感じでやる
これはもう無駄 労働力なんです
嫌で嫌でやるものでもないんです
だから普通日常生活失敗して
仕事やら何か何かで でも歯を噛んでもうやっていたんだからね
それでヴィパッサナーを教えたら
それも同じやり方でやっちゃうと結果が出てこないんですけども
まあとにかく観察すると面白くはなってきます
まあ楽しくなってくるとはちょっと置いておきますけど
面白くはなってくるはずなんです
だからすごく病気になっても
うーん 痛くなってもそれを観察している
そうすると 痛いんですが
面白い きついんですけど
面白いということがなるんです
それで冗談は言えます
変な顔にはなりません
なんで私がこんな不幸でしょうかとかね
そこで科学者って誰ですかね？みんな観察者でしょ
物事を観察したんだから
いろんな法則を見出したんでしょうね
だってものすごい重い
バカでかい もう人のもう千人はなりますかね
ジャンボジェット機とかね
かなり乗りますね もう何人いるのかわかりません
私はあまり車に興味がないんですけどね
あれほど人を乗せて また荷物やら食べ物やら何から何まで空飛ぶんだから
あの凧というんですか？あの空
あれ おもちゃの凧ですね
凧でもろくに飛ばせない我々は
でも観察能力ある人はどうですかね
飛行機作って飛ばしちゃう
観察能力ある人々は 飛行機だけじゃなくて
このもういろいろサテライトやらね
いろんなものを作って
また宇宙まで飛ばしていると
それは科学者の世界でしょうね
何か特別な能力がありますかね
別にどうってことない
観察する そこから法則を見つける
それから観察して 何かまた見つける
それで実験に実験でやってみると
その実験を観察する それから次の実験をする
それからそれを観察する
だからお釈迦様は変なことを教えてないんですよ
観察しなさいと ものすごいありがたいことを言っているのです
だから観察しちゃうと
この時間と順番ということがわかってきます
それでゼロ 無駄をにして行動することができます
それでこの観察能力ある人
ものの順番と時間というものを知っている人が仕事をすると
それこそ世界一早いです
ただ 焦っただけで早くはできません
踏ん張っただけで別に早くできません
あれあれ これやといろいろテキストを調べて調べて調べて
こう並べて並びかけて
いろいろレポート書いてレポート書いてとかね
だからで仕事を早くできるってことはないです
だから私は言うんですけど
この私が言うスローモーションできるならば
あんたスローで仕事 何でもスローでやろうとするならば早いんですよ
必ず無駄が消える それで私は瞑想していると出す
もう一つの例がありますから
大体みんな聞いてない話ですからね
個人個人的に教えますからね
その場でその場で教え方変えるしね
で この早くやりたがってる人々のこと
あんたね 早くやりたいと思って
例えば電車 駅に行って
ものすごく早く切符買おうとしてください
すごく速く走ってサッと財布を開けて
もうお金を取って入れようとすると落ちるでしょう
１枚 落ちたあのコインがグルグルッと転がっちゃって
どこかに それでどこへ行ったんでしょうかとかね
それ調べて拾って 切符をどれぐらい時間かかっているんですか？その時間とよく置いて開けます
150円ですね  150円入れます
それでボタンを押すと切符がどちらの方が早いですか？だからもう早い人と財布
こっちがこっち どっちだ
そうやってそれ時間ロスでしょう
それにだけど だから焦ってるだけで無知で
焦ってる人を見ただけでもイライラするでしょうに
無知のところなんです
だから落ち着いて順番で財布を取って開けて
焦って開けちゃうと もし切符がちょっとずれちゃったらどうしますか？開けられなくなっちゃうでしょ
そこをまた直すために
また戻して引っ張って引っ張って
それでもうまくいけばいいんだけど
それを破れちゃったらどうしようかとかね
それまたブランドのものだったらどうしようかとかね
だからそういうふうな例で考えてほしいんですよ
スローモーションというのはのんびり合いということではないんです
そこは智慧の世界で 我々の理屈の世界ではありません
ですから 訓練するときはわざとこの基本的なところでスローモーションでやっていただいて
それから 正しいスピードっていうことを慣れたそうです
正しいスピードに慣れだったら
ご飯食べる時はこれぐらいと
天ぷらを揚げる時はこれぐらいと
全部時間なりだそうです
だから天ぷら揚げると卵焼きを作る
それぞれ時間違います
だからもう焦れない人
だからプロは焦れないんだ
大体は プロは焦りません
物の順番を知っているんだから
それでプロということは観察するんだだから失敗はしません
失敗もしません だからプロを頼むんですね
仕事の場合 仕事のプロに頼んだらもう安心しますね
なんとか会社に頼みましたと
なんとか人に頼みましたと
それでも安心することができます
なぜならば プロは失敗しませんから
プロは焦りません 物の順番を知っている
ですから無駄がなく仕事をできると
と言っても失敗する場合ありますね
あれ なんでしょうかね
結構失敗しますね 世の中
結局失敗するのはみんなプロなんですけど
電車の運転間違で事故った場合あるでしょうに
何回も あれ そこら辺の誰か頼んで
子供が電車好きだから
子供は君運転しなさいと頼んだわけじゃないでしょう
かなり腕前の人々がやっていて事故しちゃうんです
なんでプロが事故っちゃうんでしょうかね
失敗するんですかね それは教慢ですよ
慣れたもんやと そんなものは目を閉じてでもできそう
あれでも必ず失敗する
で 失敗の場合はプロの方が多いんです
アマチュアの人っていうのはそれほど失敗しません
真剣にやってますから
例えばいろいろ作品を作る人がいて
我々は何かこの置物なんか作ってほしいと
で その場合はプロに頼むよりは
誰かこの趣味でやっている人に頼んだ方がいいものを作るんですよ
その人は真剣だから 私にそんなことを頼むんでしょうかと
プロに頼んだらすごいお金もかかっちゃうし
自分が作るものは作品だからね
それでやっぱりこれちょっと気に入らんということは結構あるんです
気に入らんってこと言えないんで
向こうはもう名前もう旗あげてるプロだから
それで強引に何々さんの作品だという風に看板書いといて我慢するんです
それでかっこ悪いんだ
不細工なんですけど みんなそうですか
やっぱりさすが何々さんの作品だとインチキばっかりですよ
だから有名な人であろうとも
まあまあまあそういう作品もいくらでもありますよ
それはサッカーに聞いてみてください
100体ぐらいものを作って壊すんだから
あの なんて言いますか
みんな好きでしょ？なんとかスクールで焼き物というんですかね
陶器と なんて言いますかね
陶芸です 陶芸  陶芸ですね
日本はみんな好きですけど
みんな自分が作るものを大事に持っていくんだけど
それボロ見ますよ すごい作品そこでボロ
その人は 100ぐらいそこで全部壊しちゃうんです
壊すものはどう見ても普通にちょっと教えてもらって作った人のものよりははるかにいいものです
でも壊す ということは
芸術家の世界でももう何でも芸術作品というわけじゃないんです
彫り物する人にしても
もう自分を彫ったものは何でも芸術作品って
そういうのはなりません
まあとにかくプロは失敗します
それはもう決まっています
本当は失敗するはずがないんです
で まあ陶芸みたいな場合はもう自分だけの力じゃないんだからね
自分の指先だけの力じゃないんだから
まあまあどうせたくさん気に入らない作品っていうのは出てきます
色にしたっても 自分イメージした色で出てくるかないか
それはわからない  そういういろいろありますけどね
で そうでなくて 運転士が電車のね
運転士がなんで失敗するかと
慣れたもんやと これで慣れたもんやと思っちゃうと
我々は何を忘れるんですか？観察する忘れるんです
すべて一回きりやと 二度と起こらないものやという
この一番必要なこの緊張感みたいなもの
緊張というよりも観察能力なんですよ
ああ 面白いと そこがなくなっちゃうんですね
だからバカになっちゃうんです
だからすごい単純ミスですごい出来事
事故を起こすんです 日本で起きたんだから
患者入れ替えちゃって
心停止してる こんなあり得るんでしょうかと
そんなこと もう慣れてるんだから
順番全部昔から決まってるんだから
その順番でこのやれる人でやっちゃう
そこでもうお腹が切る必要ない人は別なところで胸を切る人
別なと だから医者もバカ大バカまで平気で切っちゃって
手術までして そういうところでは別に何も悪くはないんだけど
でも切っちゃったんです
何者かとこの人々 ですから
人の体にメスを入れる前に
それはその患者さんですか？とかね
これはもう二度と起こらない出来事でしょうしね
すべて一期一会というね
禅の言葉がありますね
だからそれはすごい大事な言葉なんです
一期一会と それを忘れると
もう大変危険です プロは失敗します
ですから この 念入りの生き方っていうのはそういう生き方なんです
ただのんびりやっただけで念入りとは言えませんし
あの効率は最低低いやと
それは念入りで仕事をしているんだから
そんなことを言うなよ
何か仕事を頼んだら 1年もかかります
で 私はもうすごい念入りできちんとやっているんだから
1年かかる 本当か？そういうのは嘘ですよ
例えばたくさん注文 いい仕事をしている人で
たくさん注文が入って
自分がもう一日中仕事をしたっても
一つの仕事を終わるためには
例えば 2時間かかると
それで大量にあっちゃうと
2時間で計算すると 今日はこれ何本かっていうことはありますから
そうすると まああなたはもう来月やと
あなたは来年やとはもう時間設定はできますけど
それは怠けてるわけでも何でもないんです
それはちゃんとしたもうわかりやすい話で
ただ仕事に時間がかかったと
いうことで このすごい念入りやとは言いません
例えば包丁を研ぐ場合は
もう 3時間はかかるんだよと決めつけちゃっちゃうと
これちょっとおかしいんです
3時間もかけて包丁研いだんだから
それは素晴らしく念入りで
それだったら料理人になれませんね
それで念入りで玉ねぎを剥くと
時間かかる それで包丁を磨いて玉子を剥き終わったところでもう8時間も経っていて
もう もうじゃあ明日って
いつ食べられますかね？だから念入りっていうのはそんなもんじゃないんですよ
本当に念入りでプロが観察しながら玉ねぎの皮を剥くんだったら
誰よりも早いんです だから念入りっていうのは早いということ
効率は最高なレベルであるということ
失敗はもうほぼゼロということ
全くゼロとはそれはちょっと言えませんね
人間の感情というのもいろいろ波がありますからね
ほぼゼロということです
だから 世の中で思っていることはちょっと矛盾なんですよ
念入りに仕事をしちゃうと
多様化 効率化 もうもうスピード化
どうしますかとかね 何言ってるんでしょうかと
ちゃんと念入りで正しく観察して
順番をわかって 時間という概念を理解して仕事をすると
それが早いんです それが失敗しない
それ自体が経済です それで私は時々瞑想するときに言うんですよ
ただジャガイモの皮を剥くときでも
ただイライラして剥くんじゃなくて
観察しながら剥きなさい
そうすると時間ないんだと
そんなゆっくりできません
とも くだらないことを言うんですよ
その人によるとは一生もう無意味な人生になりますけど
私の言い分は  1個1個のジャガイモは 1個しか存在しない
そのジャガイモを剥くことは一回しかできません
だから観察する必要は必ずある
それでジャガイモの形
一個一個違う その形を見て剥くんです
この形だったらこういう風になって
この形だったらこの方が早い
この形だったらこの方が早いと無駄がないんだと
それではなくて ただ取って剥いたりしちゃうと
このちょっと形が変わっているところは残るでしょうに
そこら辺でものすごく時間取ってしまっちゃいます
玉ねぎにしたっても 一個一個違います
だから私は観察してみたところありますから
例えばある玉ねぎあります
そのまま手で潰しちゃうと
もうすぐ落ちる玉ねぎもあります
皮が それで一枚だけ手で抜けばもう終わり
それで下のヘタの後で切ってもいいんです
また ある玉ねぎはちっと皮がね
玉ねぎのものの中に糊でボンドで貼ってるようにちっとついてるんです
だから私はすぐ下を切って
前のを切って 包丁で切るんです
皮を 一枚下に包丁を入れてパッと剥いちゃうと
だから中の一枚 玉ねぎの一枚を取ってしまうんです
皮を剥こうとはしない
皮を剥せちゃうと もう粘りついてついてるんだから
これ取るのは大変なんで
時間かかります  だからどんなジャガイモも包丁を入れて皮を剥がして皮を
それはやりません ほんと無駄だから
ジャガイモのジャガイモじゃなくて
玉ねぎの一番前の皮が一番安くて量が多いんだから
玉ねぎとして それを捨てたらどうしますか？だからこの観察してやるというふうなことで
何でも面白くなってきます
それにものすごい智慧がありますよ
何でも知っておく必要はありません
なぜならば もう知っておくものは全部過去で消えちゃったんだから
もう二度と戻らないんだから
だからすべて一期一会の世界だと思うと
大体何でもできます で
例えば立派なビデオを撮るということは
プロでなきゃできませんと思ってるでしょ
ビデオのプロっていうのは
結構それに訓練を受けて
時間をかけて訓練して訓練してやってますね
それで私はある日はこのいい
いいっていうのいわゆる放送用というかね
いい作品 ビデオって何なのかというと
基本的なところをこれは言ったんですね
大事な場面を記録していること
それで何でも撮るということではありません
その出来事はどちらがどちらが大事かと
まず考えて それでどんな位置で撮った方がその記録できるかと
それは理解する必要がある
で それだけちょっと撮れば
もうきちんと作品になるんだと
それでカメラなんかはね
みんなこのもう変に撮ったり
もう上へ上がったり下がったり
いろいろそれはよくないんだと
特にカメラがぶれたりしますね
走ってる人を撮ろうと思っちゃうと
自分も走ってるんですね
それでカメラも動いていて
もう全然見られませんね
普通の人を撮っちゃうとそうなるんだ
でも走っていながら自分も走りながらプロが撮っても
写真はきちんと安定している
カメラのブレっていうものはないということ
そこら辺はもうちょっとほんのちょっと聞いただけ
別に私はテレビをじーっと見てるわけじゃないんです
ただつけておこう 仕事しなさいと
たまたまたまたま見る
見るんだけど 見た瞬間のものを覚えてるんです
それであの 自分が国へ帰って
誰かからこのカメラを 1つ借りたんです
その出来事を記録してほしいということで
カメラを借りた 借りた時はこれが推進で
これがこれでとちょっと教えてもらって
まあそこら辺はまあよくわかりますからね
で 私は生まれて初めてビデオカメラ触った
ある人 自分では撮れないんで
とにかく自分がそういういろんな仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
だから誰に頼もうかなと言ったら
カメラマンも何人かいたんですけどね
まあお偉いのことだからね
まああんたやれと言えばやってくれます
だから一人はもう自分でやりたくて
もう踏ん張っているんですね
で その人のカメラを持って
私はまあ誰か聞いたね
やっぱりあの人に頼みましょうと
まあ店も持ってますからとかね
私はね あの人撮った写真一つわしに気に入れませんと
今まで まあしょうがなく
もう使ってるんだけど
気に入れませんと だからビデオ撮ってもらったら
そういう同じことでやりませんと言ったっても
誰に任せようかなとわからない
それで田舎から自分の兄貴が来たんですね
兄貴はもうビデオカメラ触ったことがない
そこであの 私は兄貴にはこの俺
ちょっと記録してみれませんかと言ったら
使い方がわかりませんけど
と言ったら まあそれはまあ
彼もいわゆるメカニック能力はあります
それはちょっと見たらわかるでしょ
これが推進で これがオフで
これはコースで一時停止で
これがズームで それはいはいわかります
それわかったら 私はもう一つ覚えておいてくださいと
このカメラがちょっとでも動いちゃうと
これとんでもなく映像が動くんだよと
これが一つの目ですよ
だから人間も目がこうやって見ると見られませんだから目は動かない
ですから いかなる場合でもカメラだけは動かさないでください
それからこのこういう出来事だから
大事なポイントはこれとこれとこれとこれですよ
そこであなたは先に行って
その場所に走ってちょっと構えていただきなさいというと
人々は来ると前正面でさっさと撮れるようになる
それから 次のものを撮ろうとしている人は
次の大事なポイントで先に走って待っていてください
だから兄貴だから 思考パターンは大体似ていることは似ているんだから
一回はいわかりました
それで私はもう自分の兄弟だから
もう信頼するし もう忘れちゃって
その仕事で私は楽なんですね
もう彼が初めて ビデオカメラ手に取ったんです
それでまあ ２日間くらいいろいろあったんだけど
全部撮って また他の法事も彼にやってもらったんだけど
それで何も編集なしにそのまま流してみたんですよ
ビッタシで全部 だからあれ
プロに頼んだらもう何本撮ってもつなげてつなげて
かなり苦労しなくちゃいけなかったんです
私は本当に自分でもびっくりするんですね
この人はよく撮ってるなとかね
かすかにでもカメラのブレがね
時々ガビとか なかなかこの立っていられないところでも待っていたんですよ
待っていても それは体はそうなので
カメラはきちんと動かないようにきちんと握って撮っているんです
それで私はその出来事に参加せなくちゃいけないんですけど
それでもう順番でゆっくりやってましたけど
それに次の場面になってくると回っているんです
そちらに ちゃんと早く行って
ですから この物事の順番をちゃんと知って
まあやり方ちゃんとやっちゃうと
もうもうプロみたいな並みのものはできるんで
誰にでも だから言いたかったのは
別に何でも前もって訓練して準備して知っておくということは要りませんと
ただ  一期一会の世界だから
その場で観察して行動すればいいのです
それで 何回も自分の国でできる出来事に参加したことがありますから
あの このテレビ局から来るんですね
時々 あれは私はものすごい気に入らないんです
なぜかというと まあ前もって来ていろいろ調査とかするんだけど
全部人の場所を取っちゃうんですね
馬鹿げた馬鹿げた機械持ってきて
ライト持ってきて 自分勝手にあちこちライトをつけたり
自分勝手で あなた方の仕事じゃないぞ
こちらの仕事でしょうに
これに邪魔してどうするんですか？でも聞かない
向こうは放送局だから
大体そういうので 私はもう私にも仕事をしてくださいと頼まれて
私はやりませんと 嫌です
だってこちらはいろいろ計画を立てて
これはこういう風に これはこういう風にやりますよとしたで
いろんなプログラム組んだりするんだけど
うまくいかなくなっちゃうんです
時々こちらはこちらでこっちを固めておきましょうとかね
こちらはこういう風に布でちょっと飾っておきましょうとかね
向こう見たら これは邪魔だからちょっとどかしてくれと言っちゃうと
これはものすごい気持ち悪くて
ボロボロ もう何でもカビとかいっぱいあるところかもしれませんよ
まあ向こうの事だからね
そこを開けて置いちゃうと
向こうのカメラにライトの邪魔だからって
普通来ている人々にとってはすごい気持ち悪いこと見えるんだから
そこはこちらでこれを綺麗に見せるために
これちゃんと隠しておいたんだから
でもこうやって私はその時は腹が立つんです
冗談じゃない 随分もうコソコソと決めて計画立てて
みんな徹夜してね 若い者はもう 2日
3日徹夜していっぱいやったものだから
だからその場合 私は大体はもう協力はできませんと断りますと
下の仕事はしません  脚通してきてなんとかしなさいと言ったら
それでも考えて じゃあ来ますよと
まあこの間も 3日  3回
すごい国際的ななんかやりますからどうぞ来てください
私ははい わかりました
そのうち考えますと言って行かなかったんです
で なぜかで そこを邪魔したり
いろいろめちゃくちゃなことになるんだから
だからまあとにかくこのボロってもそうやって迷惑をかけたりもする
で 知恵の世界で一期一会で生きている場合は
その その雰囲気に合わせて
まあ仕事をいい仕事をすることはできます
それが念入りということなんです
何が一番正しいか 何が一番早いか
どうすれば失敗ないか
そこらへん観察することは念入りなんです
包丁はどのように取るべきか
どのように切りべきか
どこから始まりますか
その順番を知って その順番で
だから忘れることはなくなっちゃう
ストレスもたまりません
ずっと観察するとすごく面白くなる
そこで瞑想する方々は
このすごくこの考えていることばかりを集中力という
すごくそれは期待しているんですね
で 私がこのいろんなみんな瞑想について妄想はいっぱいあるんだけど
瞑想は知らないんですね
サマーディ瞑想やとかね
で ヨーガ瞑想はやこうだとか
よくよく喋るといろんな文章が見ると
もう人かけらも知らないんではないの
だからもうそういう風な風なこの経験もなしに
単なる妄想すること 情報が頭に入って
それを目指して集中力つくろやとわかってない
そこで私はものすごくきつく読んで
集中力っていうのは興味ですよ
なんかこの人は変なことばっかり言ってるんだから
もういいとしようと それで処理しようとしてるんです
なんで私の言葉がものすごく
今までの固定概念とは違うんだよと
そんなにもしつこくしつこく言うんだから
そんなにも自信満々で言うんだから
ちょっとやってみたらどうですかね
世の中みんなもう集中力やとかね
私は己は忘れたんだと
なんて言いますか 自分とすべてのものが一体になりましたと
神と合体しましたと いろんなことを言うんだけど
じゃあ犬と合体したらどうですかね
俺だったら で そういう話に乗せられちゃって
そんなこの概念に乗せられても足を引っ張られちゃうんです
だからチャレンジしてほしいんです
集中力っていうのは興味ですよ
インタレストですよ 興味ですよ
それで観察するとインタレスト
興味という英語の単語がありますけど
皆さんもご存知だと思いますけど
私の発音が変だからわからないかもしれません
そのインタレスト 興味
いわゆる興味ですよ 日本訳は
なんか興味あるんだと
興味津々とか何とか言葉がありますね
ただそれだけ それやったら奇跡的に仕事を何でもできるでしょう
どんなものにでも興味持ってみてください
なんのことなく淡々とできるでしょ
あ これ面白いやと これそんなに大したこと
難しいことですかね だって全て一回きりでしょうに
だから知恵と一緒に集中力っていうのは生まれてくるんです
だから集中力がないと知恵が生まれてきません
だからお釈迦様はサマーディがないとパンニャーがない
智慧がないんだと お釈迦様おっしゃってます
そこはまた自分の固定概念に解釈して
これは 20年  40年瞑想して
神と一進化することを
誰かと一体になること
森羅万象と自分とも自我が消えて全部一つになる
そういう神秘経験があってから
それから智慧が生まれる
こういう計画立てたりして
もうものすごい道が違うんですね
それ何もやらない そういう人々の
ただ行者で宗教家で神秘家で終わっちゃうんですね
この神秘家っていうのは
大槻久司に合わせちゃうとね
そんな超能力あればな
すぐバレますから ですからこのお釈迦様
すごい科学的なことを教えますから
やっぱりこの観察する
で そこで興味が生まれてくる
そうすると見えてくる
それが知恵なんです 順番と時間の流れとありとあらゆるもの
そういうことかと だからサマーディとパンニャーはいつでも一緒なんです
それは離れることはできません
興味もない 面白くもないものはできませんよ
人間には 食べたくもないものは食べられますかね
聞きたくもない音楽を聞こえます
聞きますかね 見たくもないものを見られますかね
なんでそんなバカなことをやるんですかね
見たくないんだったら見なきゃいいでしょうし
聞きたくないものは聞かなきゃいいでしょうし
食べたくもないものは食べなくてはいい
食べな 食べないでよろしいでしょうし
ですから この観察すると
物事については興味が生まれてくる
それは集中力なんです
専門用語で言えば 一境性という
このアビダンマでも翻訳までしているんだから
一境性 一つの対象にじっと心を絞っているんだ
それは神秘体験という風に言う必要ないんです
だから本なんか読みたくない私も
あのハリーポッターのシリーズは全部いっぺんに読んでしまっちゃったんだから
4冊が 5冊がもう買って
ああ開けたら面白い それでとにかくもうそのままずっと終わりまで
読んでしまっちゃったんです
自分でももう自分のバカバカさに笑いながらね
で とにかくそちらで書いている世界はもうなんか面白くなってきたんですね
で 子供見る目ではなくて
大人の目で読んだんですけど
やっぱりきちんとそのローリングさんというのは
子供の心をちゃんと把握して
よく計算して書いてるんだというね
だいぶちっちゃな子供たちの世界をね
綺麗に書いてるんだから
ああ それは面白いと 一人の大人として興味を持って終わりまで読んでしまったんですね
かなりすごいんですよ
量は 日本語版見たことはないんですけど
あの まあとにかくそんなもんで
興味が出てきたら もうどんな仕事もものすごい軽々と終わっちゃう
それで読んで終わって
私は目が疲れた 腰が痛い
全然ないんだから 風が吹こうがもう全然気にしません
もう読んでるから 時間が経とうが
それはもう気にしない
ですから もう奇跡的に仕事はできるんですよ
だから興味さえあれば
だから興味こそが幸福なんです
楽しいんですよ だから病気になったら落ち込むんじゃなくて
興味持って自分の病気
病気に対処するってことを言いたいんですよ
興味持ってください これが不幸で亡くなっちゃうんです
たとえ病気で死んじゃって当たり前のことだからね
みんな死んじゃいますからね
それでも それまたすごい面白くなってくるんですね
この辺で この２日前からませ
体調がものすごく最悪な状態でもうものすごいもう
もうすごい悪かったんですね
すごい体が調子が悪い
で 食べ物とかにとってももう嫌っていうことで
で でもすごい悪かったんで
とにかくまあ悪いんだけど
まあこれ寝た方がいいやと
寝られないし で まあまあ
それでもまあちょっとまあある工夫をして寝たんです
寝て夢見たんです 夢は何を見たんですかというと
自分の論理性は全部腐って消えていくんですね
なんか皆様はあまりこういうややこしい夢見ないと思いますけど
私の言われてる人にちょっと言いにくいんですよ
なんかすごい違いますからね
自分のこの喋るよりは厳密に論理的なんですけど
頭の中はね まあ喋る時はその論理的に喋れませんしね
そこでこの厳密な論理性が全部この腐りかけて
脳細胞までね 全部腐って崩れていく
そこで私は何か何か誰かに何か言ったんですね
まあそれは仏教のことなん言った瞬間に
あ これはものすごい論理的じゃないんだと
全く合ってないんだと言って
あ なるほど これで終わりかと
あ これでただのただの肉の塊になったんだよと
という風な もうなんか夢見たんで
それあんまり面白いから誰かに言おうかなと思ったんだけど
公に言うことになってしまっちゃったんです
言ったらこれから気をつけてください
なんか夢でこの論理は全部
いわゆる脳の機能は全部この腐りかけて消えていくんですね
そこでまた自分が客観的にまた観察する
観察する癖がついてるんだから
だから夢でも変ですよ
とにかく普通とは違う
夢見ている自分をまた観察するんだからね
それで自分の論理性を腐りかけていくことは
観察しているのがそれまた逆に言えば論理的なんですけど
それでただの動物やらみんなと同じく
もう何もない ただの動いている肉の塊になってしまったと
じゃあこれから喋るのは大変だと
気をつけなくちゃいけないんだと
やっぱり喋らない方がいいんじゃないかなと
そういう風ないろいろなことを思っているつもりで
またまあまあ 夜も終わって
まあ全部目覚めたんですけどね
ですから この 興味というものを持ちちゃうと
きちんとこの物事を論理的に見えて面白くなってくるわけです
だから言いたかったのは
そうやって自分がこの死にかけていたって思う
どういったことないんです
そんなこと それは観察しなさいと
だから私はまだ死にかけたことがないんだけど
まあちょっと調子が悪かったら夢ででも死にますね
結局は 一回かなり前なんですけど
かなり体調が悪くて倒れたって状態になって
まあ別にもうもうもうちょっと胃が故障
故障しただけなんですけどね
そこでもう頭もちょっと調子が悪くて
まあ寝込んじゃったんだけど
夢でお墓ばっかし この火葬している
次から次へと見えてくるんで
それでいろいろまあその中に筋を入れて
まあそれを火葬して また他のところでまた誰かを火葬して
次の俺の順番ですねとか待ってるんですね
夢で死んでるんです 死んでいて
それで俺の順番だからって待っていると目覚めちゃったんです
だからこの夢で自分が死ぬことになっても面白いんですよ
だから実際に死ぬことになっても
それを面白く観察すれば
だからずっと人生ってすごい幸福で終わるんです
だから仏道においては焦りはなし
余計に焦って早くやるということは
これは禁止 緊張することも禁止
これをすべて無知ということ
だから観察しなさいと
一生 それは念入りっていうのは違う意味なんですけど
仏教では念というサティという言葉を使ってるのはそのわけなんです
だから悟った人のことを説明している
あるところでサダーサティ
サティーマ サダー 常に永遠に常住しているんだ
サティ サティと自分が一体になっているんだ
そういうふうな表現での悟りを表現しているんです
だから悟りと自分が一体感になったら
まあこれ以上幸福から強さがないんです
観察すると自分というのは
自分というものは固定しているわけじゃないで
これも変わって変わって変わって
一期一会だから体もずっと変わっている
ですから   観察ということでずっと生きている
自分の生き方と観察は一体になる
悟ったところ もう妄想なんかは入り込まない
だから普通の世界ではみんな本当にかわいそうに無理をしているんで
それは猿に数学を教えることと同じなんです
これ無理ですよ すっごい小さな時
猿を飼って育てて もう １と２見せて
１と１を見せて それで２の看板取ったら
あのもう豆 １個あげるとかね
もうオレンジ １個あげるとか
そこを何回もやってやって
そんなことで別にすごく分かったことわけないでしょう
だから私たちのやり方は早くやりなさい
無駄を省きなさい 効率を良くしましょうと
経費削減しましょうとか
何言うんでしょうかと
無理やと だから日本はバブルになってしまって
経済状態はすごく危険な状態になって
いまだに立ち上がっていない
だからその時も私にはこのこの場合はこうすればいいのにとかね
この場合はこうすればいいのにとかね
その場でその場で頭にパッパッと浮かぶんだけどもね
まあ誰も聞いてくれませんだからね
聞いたって誰も実行できないと思いますよ
普通人間考えることじゃないんだから
でも自分にとってはこれ実行すれば最高にいいじゃない
100%問題は そこで自分に浮かんだものでも
みんなプロの方々だから
たまたま言う方々いるんですよ
言う時はもうかなり時間経っとっているんですね
それテレビなんかで聞いてもう遅いんだと
それやっても と自分の気持ちなんです
それはもうちょっと  2年
3年前で思い浮かんで実行していたならばよかったんだけども
ですから この普通の世の中で
このサティの機能 観察の機能について
それからものの順番について
時間について まるっきり無関心だから
効率よく 頑張ろうといっても
無駄省きませんったって
もうやめときゃいいんです
無駄しかしませんし もう無駄な浪費しかしませんしね
そういう世界なんだから
自然破壊して 我々も互いに殺し合って死んだり
もう苦労してもうキリがなく終わっちゃいます
だから全くもお釈迦様はこの違う世界を見ているます
えーと そこら辺で少々休憩いたします
えーまたいくつかポイント思いだったら喋りますと
ありがとうございます
これはよく世界では社会でね
あの いろいろトラブルの起きたり
あの まあお尻を叩かなくちゃいけないということはよく出てくる
それでこの効率とかね
なんとか経済的な計画立てたりする
それでうまくいかないということがあるんですね
それはなぜかというと
これは仏教で一般的に言う
この欲なんですね 欲と怒りなんですね
欲で儲かることを経済
それは将来の思考なんです
これぐらい儲かりますと
これぐらいものは作りますと
これぐらい売りますと
まずそういう計画 将来的な計画を立てて
社員やら労働者をいじるんですよ
早く早く早く頑張れ そうするとどうやればうまくいくかといって
もう何でもする 残酷なことでも
お金がたくさんかかる
だったらみんな首やリストラやとかね
で そういうふうにも何でもする
それで会社作品を作る
工場がちょっと見せたんだけど
この会社から経営削減なんとかのことで
この一回 このなんとかに機械に入れる場合は
今まで 4つしか入らなかったと
それで入れて一遍に 4つ作るんだと
向こうを開けて 6つにしなさいと
それでその仕事をされて
だけど 6つにしちゃうと上手くいかないんだと
あまり品質は良くないんだと
だからそこで品質のことじゃなくて
あの  6つ入れちゃうとすごいお金が安くなる
一回工程を置いてもうできたところで 6つできてるんだから
前だったら 6つ作るためには 2回やらなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そこで 2回やったら 8個出てくるし
今度は 1回やると 6つで 2回やると 12個だから
そこで計算で安いと で
いたってもそれではちょっと困りますとか何とか言って
それでもしょうがないと
そういうふうに作っているんだと
だから そういうふうに
この作品とかなんとかということで考えているんだけど
彼らが一つ忘れているんですね
儲かる額なんか先に決める
で そこで先に決めて これぐらい儲からなくちゃいかないんだと
そこにあるのは欲なんですね
それに怒りがあるんで
競争ということですからね
であの会社より先にこちらは新しいモデルを発表しなくちゃいけないんだ
そこで早く早く何か作って発表しなさいよと言って
会社のその設計する人々をいじめたりする
そちらも焦って あちこち走って
なんとかでも新しいアイデアが出て
新しいデザインモデルが出てくるのは技術的なことをかなりやるんだから
落ち着いて気持ちよく穏やかに遊びでやらないと出てこないんですよ
いい作品というのは それであんまり責められているのだから
とにかくなんとかあちこち旋回でなんとかで作っちゃいますけどね
それで作った作品というのは
ただ変わっているだけで役に立つか立たないかって問題がある
だからそれで他社とは競争するという
これより先にやらなきゃということで
この怒りが入ってるんですね
それは会社スケールで
個人個人でもたくさん仕事をしなくちゃいけないと欲が入っちゃうんですね
この欲っていうのは将来のことなんですよ
これぐらい仕事をこれぐらいのをやってやるぞ
それでもうライバル意識で
あの人よりたくさんやらなくちゃいけない
それで欲と怒りで能力なくなっちゃうんです
観察能力消えちゃうんですね
だから一つも上に行かないんです
それで計画について語りますけど
計画っていうのは決してその通りにはいかないんです
だから計画できるのは
このものの順番と時間というものをわかっている時なんです
例えば もう再来年 車これぐらい台数売りますよと思っても
その再来年になった時
その時の世界の経済状態
それによって売れる台数を決めますから
こちらで勝手に決めてもね
買うのは自分じゃないんだからね
そこでたくさんの車を作っても売れないと
作ったお金は全部赤字になったと
すると泣いたりするんだから
だからその計画というのはやたら立てるもんじゃないんですよ
能力ないんです 計画立てる人々に
だからこの本当に計画を立てられるのは
ブッダが教えたこの観察能力ある人
一期一会だということをわかっている人にだけなんです
一回しか成り立たないんだと
それでこのある新聞記事を読みましたけど
外国の新聞で 日本新聞か覚えてない
まあ日本新聞ですね 英字新聞ね
このアメリカがもうずっとテロの的になっちゃいますよ
なぜかというと これ アメリカ人がこの大型思考ね
車はばっかでかい車ばっかし買うんだと
もうトラックみたいな車に乗ってあちこち行ったりするなんて
それはものすごい もう燃費食っちゃいますよ
だからもうアメリカは自分でも石油は作らないし
作ろうと思えば作れるではないか
だからアラビアとかそういう国に定期的に損益お金を払わなくちゃいけないと
自分払ったお金で自分を殺されることになっちゃいますよと
だからもうちょっとこのあまりにもエネルギースゴいことは考えたらいかがでしょうかという
これは外国人に言ったらとんでもないことになりますから
記者はアメリカ人なんですね
で だからそれでさっさとこんな大胆なことを書いてる人は誰ですか？と聞いたら
それはアメリカの大変なこのもうプロ中のプロのジャーナリストなんですね
で その瞬間で私は思い出したのは
日本もすごい経済状態でも苦しんでいますね
でもかえって日本というのは大型化ではなくて
この小型化で商売繁盛してたんでしょう
それで でも日本の世界も欧米の学んで大型化にチャレンジするんですね
車やら何でも大型もの
大きいもの作ろうではないかとかね
それだったら負けると
どう計算しても資源が減っていくんですよ
二酸化炭素が増えていくんですよ
自然が壊れていくんですよ
それで日本に技術はあるんだから
科学者もいっぱいいるんだから
研究者もいっぱいいるし
大体一人一人でもみんななかなかのプロでしょうし
だから個人個人で でもこのもうこのエネルギーの違うエネルギーを使うことを研究して
例えば全くのもうもうもう電池で電気だけで動くもう自動車を設計するとかね
もうすごい普通の水やら普通の空気やら
そういうもので あのもうエネルギーを作るとか
方法を開発するとかね
考えればいくらでも出てくると思いますけどね
それは今設計したっても金にならないかもしれません
でもこちらでそういうものを設計していれば
この公害ゼロだと それで燃費に困らなくてもいいんだと
言っちゃうと やがてアメリカもみんなそれへ合わなくちゃいけないことになるんですね
だから この先を読むということは
そういうふうに先を読んだ方がいいんですよ
だから必ずそうなるということは
いくらでもあるんですよ
それは順番でわかるんですよ
石油は必ず減る 必ず消えると
これは決まってるんです
それでどんどん石油の値段が上がる
上がれば上がるほど 石油を作る国にお金が溜まる
溜まれば溜まるほど傲慢になって
世界の平和を壊すということにはもう決まっていることでね
だからそこら辺でまたこの財産はスムーズにばらまけるようにどうすればいいかというね
そういうふうにこの大胆に計画立てない
こちら大胆っていうのは
今日は今年は 20 万台だから
来年は 40 万台だと こんなものただの欲だけでね
そんなものは計画ではありません
だから計画は立てられないと思いますよ
だから計画というのは将来のことですよ
あなたは将来わかってるんですかね
わからないでしょう 例えばアメリカのテロ事件でも誰も予測しなかったでしょう
いきなりもうたった 30 分で
もう建物が壊れて それだけで世界経済がガタガタ壊れてしまいましたね
だからたった 30 分十分ですよ
世界経済も壊れるためには
だからそんなものは何一つの計画に入ってないでしょうに
それで壊れた瞬間に 私は日本だったらこういうことをした方がいいなと思っちゃったんだけどね
やってなかったんです
だからみんなと一緒に引きずり死にちゃいますから
もうだから死ぬのは脳じゃないんだからね
誰かが自殺するなら 自分も一緒に引きずられて自分も死ぬという
それは普通にまああんた勝手にいないとあれかと思いますけど
その方がね 自殺したい人は一人でさせればいいでしょうし
だから これちょっと悪い考え方なんですけど
まあどうかで西洋の方で経済状態がすごく悪くなっても
だから日本も赤字にならなくちゃいけないと誰が決めたんですかね
アメリカの方がすごい状態悪いと
でも日本の方が大丈夫だと
という状態決して悪くないんです
だからちゃんとした計画だったら
何があってもその状態っていうのは維持することができるんですね
だからその人々っていうのは将来ということをわからないんですよ
何が起こるか それがわかったふりをして
今年はこれぐらい商売してたんだから
それはもう去年と考えると十パーセント経済成長やと
では来年も十一点パーセントにしましょうとかね
こんなのは計画ではありません
それで数字計算するんですね
これは単純だからね もう電卓使うと心にできます
もうできますから そんなもので分厚いレポート書いて
もう数字ばっかり並べて
もうレポート出して計画書やと
私まで仏教みたいな この世間から離れている人々から見れば
もう自然破壊やと この紙は無駄やと
こんなにうまくいくはずがないでしょうと
いうともうなんか我々のこと変な目で見るんですけどね
何でも悲観的やと 悲観的じゃないんです
徹底的なもうはっきり言うだけのことで
仏教の悪いところはもうちゃんと言うんですよ
それは不快を感じるかもしれませんだけどね
だから普通のもう怪しい仏教徒だったら
うまくいけばいいなとかね
うまくいってほしいなとか
この希望を述べるだけで
私もうまくいってほしいなと思う
それは自分個人の希望だけであってね
別に何の意味もないんですけどね
ですから計画を立てるという場合は
このそれ時間ということをよく考えてほしいんですよ
そこで全く予測できないものもあって
いくらか予測できるものというものは
この時間の流れで見えてくるんですね
だから必ずしも 例えば今経済のことを喋ったんだから言いますけど
必ずしもあの予測できるものはこのエネルギーの問題
だから我々には選択一つしかない
二つしかない エネルギー使うことはどんどんどんどん下げるか
あるいは新しい自然に優しい自然を守る新しい
全く新しいエネルギーを作り出すか
どちらかなんです だからその二つの方向でって考えてみるとね
例えばヨーロッパだったら
まあ車使うなよと エネルギーは削減するんだよと言って
年取ってる人々は車処分してくれれば
一年間タクシー代券とかなんとかとあげますとか
そういう風なことまでして
まあそれはもう削減の方向に行っている
それでその国々は経済的にはすごい大変なそうじゃないんです
動いてるんです まあだからこのただ単にこのみんな早く仕事をしましょう
経費削減してかなり儲かるようにしましょう
いっぱい作りましょうと言ったって
こんなものはもう猿に数学をするようなことで
みんな苦労しているだけなんです
計画立てる人にしたっても
なかなか大変で苦労するし
やられる側 この仕事をする人々はね
労働出す人々にとってはもう大変な
そういう意味で その数字に合わせるということはね
それで合わせない場合は
もうあなたはリストラ
リストラ リストラとかね
すごく簡単 だから 例えば人がリストラになったということ自体も
初めからも問題あったんですね
余分に人が使っていたということになる
リストラしたって会社が健康的だったら
本当にとんでもないことを初めからやっていたことになります
それで会社設計するとか
仕事を取るということは
みんなに仕事を与えるということが基本的であって
だからリストラというのは決して良くないことなんです
だから計画を立てる場合は
このみんなに仕事があるような計画も作らなくちゃいけないし
そこら辺が貪瞋痴ではなくて
慈しみが必要なんです
みんなに仕事があるようなことをしましょうと
だからよくインドに我々の国々のみんなよく文句を
日本人もよく文句を言うんですよ
なんでレンガなんかってもう担いで建物作る時に運んでいるんでしょうかと
これでボーンと荷車で持ってきて
ボーンと出せばそれで終わるでしょうと
やりません いったん その人たちの仕事
給料上げるような だから年仕事をしているのは労働なんですけど
仕事をして それでなんとか食べて家族を養っているし
それであんた方人もクビ
これから機械使いますと
ということをしませんね
だから経済成長ないんではなくて
例えばインドはなかなかそんな簡単に倒れる国ではないしね
アメリカにね ずっと長い間経済制裁していたでしょうに
インドは全然気にしなかったんです
それでまあ経済制裁をやめますと
ああ そうですか まあ別に関係ないと総理が言うんですよ
そんなこと別にそんな関係ないんだと
インドは倒れませんと
だから このまあ それはまあ仏教的なやり方ではなくても
インド的なやり方なんですけど
変えれば違う形で商売する
アメリカ人に日本 インドで会社やらやるなんて言ったら
まあみんなインド人がすぐインターネットやらそういうものを使って
もうずっともう商売あのまんまでやってるんです
形変えて で 自然破壊にもね
すごい緊張するし まあとにかく計画っていうのは予測できる将来があって
予測できない将来があって
その 2つを合わせて計画立てなくてはいけない
欲でできるわけじゃないんです
決して数字で考えたらいけないんです
どれぐらいお金儲かるかどうか
それは考えちゃいけない
あまり成長しない方向で考えるならば
私は 100人に仕事を与えたいとかね
考えた方がいいんですよ
その場合は その人は欲じゃなくて
100人が仕事をしてみんなで仲良くすることをそれが楽しがってるんですね
私は 100人にも仕事を与えているんだよと
そういう場合は いくらか 100人
どうすれば 100人に仕事あるかというふうに原題で考えるんですよ
原罪で それは負けです
将来ではなくて だから
でも経済成長とかを目標といっちゃえば
ちょっとスピードはすごく減るんだけど
経済的にはダメになることはないんです
そこである経済学者の人がものすごく怒鳴ったんですね
この経済成長の数字なんか持ってきてね
でもうこの経済状態が何で
あんたいい加減なこと言うなよと
この数字が経済成長はこれぐらい
それが何の意味すらいますか？人間にとっては
何の意味もないでしょうと
そんな数字を持ってきて
あの国は豊かだ この国は豊かだと言ったのは
自分の国がすごい豊かじゃなくて貧しいどん底やと
日本なんか見たらね すごく豊かでしょうと
これこれぐらい GG なんとか GMP なんとかな
これいい加減なことを言うなよ
自分で考える余裕がある
どちらに余裕があるんだと
あるんでしょうか どちらの人が笑って生活しているんですか？よく考えてもらいます
突然 スリランカの人の家に 3人が来たとします
で 我々は困りますか？その人にご飯どうしましょうか？寝るところどうします？全然困らないでしょ
あ どうぞ 日本の家で突然 3人が帰ってきたら
どうなる？入ってきたらどうになりますか？だから突然 3人が入ってきたら
こちらは食事してあげて寝かせて寝させてあげることができないんだから
でも 数字で見ると最高なように見えますよ
数字では そちらではもうすごい究極的な最新型の冷蔵庫もあって
電子レンジもあって クーラーもあって
暖房もあって まあ大概あるものはね
あるかもしれませんだけど
だからまあ この質で見るんだよ
命で見るんだよ 豊かかないかっていうことはね
人間が幸福でいるか 楽しがっているか
ストレス溜まってないか
怯えているかないか 将来について不安とか
そこが数字だよ だからその枠には入りません
だから日本でもいろいろアンケート取ったら
あなたは今の経済状態に満足していますか？満足していないか
大体はこの六十パーセント
六十五パーセントの人々は全く満足できるんだよと言った時あります
その時は私はなるほど豊かな国だなと
その時は認めます なぜかというと
別にお金がこれぐらいとかのことはないので
自分がただ自分の今の生き方に満足しているんだと
ですから この将来のことを考えて立てる計画
計画というのはすごく気をつけた方がいいんですね
そういうことだから 問題がいろいろ起きちゃいますよ
で あの よく言う  例えばね
まあ本当は今の状況でみんな考えてるんですよ
今一億円儲ければいいんだよと
だったらもういろいろ生産できますよ
それでですから 来年一年一億円儲かりましょうというふうに計画立てるでしょう
来年になったらもうどれぐらいもわからないでしょうに
状態が 例えば今 天ぷら食べたいなと思ったりしますね
今日はもう食べられません
とにかく状況でもうなんか食べて
で 明日も休みが暇がなくて食べられなかったとしても
それで三日四日経ったところで
あ 時間があって そこら辺天ぷら屋さんもいて
じゃあ行って天ぷら食べましょうったっても
それでいいんですかね
その時は天ぷら食べたいか
他の食べ物食べたいか
その時の感情でしょうに
だから食べたくなったんだから
いつか食べますよという計画は成り立たない
私は天ぷらが食べたくなったんだから
じゃあ来年あるいは来月
この日にちで食べますよと計画しても
今の感情で考えているので
今食べたいんですよ 今だったら美味しいではないかというイメージがあるんです
でも その時期になってみるとどうかわからないんですよ
それはまあ 私はよく思い出しているのは
私は私がステレオを買った例なんですけど
小さい時はまあ誰でも音楽好きになっちゃいますから
音に敏感だからね いいステレオ欲しいなと思ってたんです
それでやがて買えるぐらいお金が入って
買ってしまったんですけど
聴かなかったんです 処分したんです
それが面白くないです
もっと年取ってるのに
だからこのお金があればいい機械買ったらね
綺麗なさつそうのないね
音を聴けるでしょうとかね
思ってして でも高くて買えない
それでいろいろ仕事はいいことしていたんだから
お金がもう買えるんじゃないかと
買ってしまったんですけど
それをお金貯めるまで時間かかったんです
年取っちゃったんです
もうもう他のことにいろいろ忙しくて興味があって
こんな暇も余裕もないと
だから無駄ということなんですね
だから将来性 将来っていうのはそんなもんでわからない
そこでライバル意識でね
腹が立って仕事すること自体怒りですからね
自分をもう燃やしてるんですよ
もう余計 だからもう能力消えちゃいます
それ自体すごい浪費なんです
だから百百キロ走る人がものすごいエネルギー
最初に全部使い切っちゃうとまあ十キロで終わっちゃいますからね
だからもう相手のことを気にして
相手の会社のことを気にして
相手の仕事ぶりを気にして
それはもういろいろチェックしたり観察したりして
それで自分を調整するっていうことはありえない
無理なことなんです それは本当は綺麗さっぱり忘れた方がいいんです
相手はどんなスピードで何の仕事をしても関係ないんですよ
例えば誰かさんがね オリンピックで金メダル取ったんだから
私にとってそれは関係ないんですよ
私には取れるわけでもないし
そんな年でもないし あの
なんで人と比べるかと
だからライバル意識ってのはものすごい恐ろしいです
それと自分の能力を全部消してしまっちゃう
自分で自分の能力の裾にものすごいあちこち穴開けちゃうと
もう全部能力無駄に漏れてしまいます
だからもう仕事 ライバルの人がどれほどスピーディーで
どれほど立派に仕事をしても関係なく
自分の仕事は淡々とやることなんです
それで自分の上の人があの田中はこれぐらい仕事をしたんですけど
なんで木村はこれぐらいですか？いや
それは田中だから これは木村だから
言えばそれだけのことで
田中は木村ではありませんし
木村は田中では 田中ではありません
とにかくこの観察能力がある人の仕事の質はいいんですよ
１００個仕事をしたっても
それほど立派なものでないと
１０個をしたっても それはすごく立派だと思ったら
それはもう何も無駄じゃないんだから
だから自分が自分のエネルギーを丁寧に全部綺麗に仕事にするから
余計に人に嫉妬して怒って
ライバル意識を持って
それに無駄に燃やしてはいけない
この怒りっていうのはものすごいエネルギー消すんですよ
すごいエネルギー消すんです
ガタガタ体が倒れる 内臓がものすごいこのアドレナリンや悪いホルモンを出しちゃって
全部壊れる 脳が動かなくなっちゃいます
まるっきり智慧がなくなっちゃう
知識も動かなくなっちゃう
だって どんな人でもものすごくカンカン怒ったら
もう最低なバカなことするでしょうよ
ものすごく怒ったら 教授でも学者でも政治家でも誰でも
ただのもう猿みたいな行動するでしょ
だから怒りが良くないっていうことははっきりしています
このストレスから全ての病気っていうのは
怒りから早くも燃えて燃えて燃えて
年取って老けてしまっちゃうんです
だからいい仕事をしたい
失敗はしたくない 落ち着いていたい
常に楽しいたい 人生は楽しみたい
なんで苦労してまで生きている必要あるんですかね
どうせ死ぬ結果ですからね
だったら １秒 １秒楽しくいればいいじゃないですか
そういう人々は やっぱりこの怒りはもうにはもう完璧にさようならと言った方がいいんですね
競争心理 ライバル意識には完璧にさようならと言った方がいいです
ライバルと戦うんじゃなくて
できればライバルも助けてあげた方がいいんです
その方がものすごく自分の仕事に仕事がうまくいくんです
それは私は経験済みなんです
私は一度もライバルたちとは戦ったことがない
ライバルだと思ったのは向こう側が思っただけであって
だから私はその瞬間思ったのは
あなた方は完璧に負けるんだよと
かわいそうやと 持っている能力さえも全部みるみるうちに消えていくんですね
それ見ると もう見ていられないんですよ
じゃあいろいろ協力しますと
知らないことを教えたり
知らないことをいろいろ
いろんなもういろんな面で協力までしてあげたんです
では頑張ってください
私を倒すためにと それ怒りで言ったわけじゃないんです
本当に心配したんです
かわいそうじゃないかと
これも一人一人の人間はね
みんな完璧に生きて死んでほしいんですよ
なんで途中で失敗するんだ
それを見ていられないんだから協力します
だからライバルに協力したんだからって
自分の能力が消えるって
これはありえないことなんです
全然世界でそれわかってないんですよ
だからまあ 世の中っていうのはこんな感じで
だから私は猿の数学っていうのはそのわけで言ったんで
苦労はするんだけど 結果はないと
だから このまるっきり違うブッダの目で見てやってみると
大変なすごいいい世界が出てきます
それで 一応話は基本的には終了しますけど
このテーマ送った人が全く別なものを考えて
私にこういう質問を置いてくれたんですよ
自分という人間がマニュアルモードで行動するか
オートパイロットモードで行動するかということについて話す
考えてます で 皆さんはわかってないでしょうね
マニュアルモードとオートパイロットモードって何なのか
で ここでこの我々の日常生活で生きている場合は
我々 2つの生き方をしているんです
それはこれ言ってるのに
一つはマニュアルモード
いわゆる誰かが決めて
こういう風にこういう風にしなさいと
我々はただ操り人形の形で言われた通りにする
それで安全だと思っている人々はいます
もう一つはオートパイロットモードで
でもう 24歳になったんだから
じゃあ結婚しましょうと
まあ仕事をしましょうと
そういう風な感じで まあただ自然のままで流されて生きていると
で そのについてなんですけどね
それでオートパイロットモードは使いますか？役に立つことがありますか？ただ危険なだけですか？という
まあオートパイロットモードについて
そこでオートパイロットプログラムは身体に組んでありますか？心に組んであるのですか
よく身体で覚えろと言ったりしますが
まあそこら辺は別な講義やらないと説明難しいんですけど
あの オートパイロットモードっていうのは
まあ誰でもやることですよ
まあどんな子供でも 14 と言っちゃうと
もう反抗する 喧嘩する親と
決まってることをね で
18 になるとまたやることはまた決まっていて
そんなもので 我々もやっぱりそこはあるんですよ
40歳になったら何するか
50歳で何するか  80歳何するかと
もう全部決まっていて
だから若者の原宿がありまして
おばちゃんとおば様たちの原宿もありますね
やっぱり年取ってくると
みんなもう巣鴨に行くとかね
で 二十歳以下だったら
もう原宿か渋谷に行くとかね
こんなもの決まってます
今の我々の子供たちでも
今 10歳とかなるかもしれません
これ 16 になって 15 になってみてください
渋谷 原宿の方にもううろうろしているんです
だからまあ自分たちは新しいことをやっているつもりなんですけど
みんな結局は同じことをやっている
だからすごい派手におしゃれするとかあるでしょ
女の子たちはね みんなすごいことやってるつもりですけどね
でもどんな女の子でも
その年になると同じことをやるんです
そこでずっとそういうことがある
それから この 特に日本の職人の職人の世界では
この体で覚えるということをよく言っていますけどね
その場合もこのオートパイロットモードではないかというふうに思っているわけ
だから ちゃんと頭で覚えるんじゃなくて
体で覚えなさいと そうすると失敗なくうまくいこんだという話もあります
それはどちらに組み込まれているんでしょうかという質問なんですけど
それは体にも心にも 2つあります
オートパイロットモード
例えば男の人は 14 になってきたら
もう女の子のこと気になる
気になるの それはもう体に組み込まれているんです
14 まではもうだらしないんですよ
いくらもうかっこよくさせようと思ったって
全然気にしません  14 になってくると
かなり自分の髪型やら着る服やら
これなんだかんだ見て気になる
かっこよく見せようではないか
異性に対しては 小さい時は女の子は蹴ったり打ったり殴ったり
もう相手にしない 遊び相手にも気に入らない
それでちょっと裏ちゃうとかなり違います
えらい親切で丁寧で というまあ私は男の心は一応ね
まあ知ってるんだから言ったんですけど
女の子もそれなりのプロセスがあると思いますけどね
で見ると面白いんですけど
それが体に組み込まれてるんですね
DNA とかね そこら辺で
それにもう一つ 心にもそうやってプログラムは組み込まれています
ちょっとしたことで怒ると
何気にでも文句を言うと
ブーブーとか それは小さい時から見えるんですよ
そこでもう一生 もういくら大人大きくなっても
その時のことにブーブーと文句を言う
兄弟でいつでも喧嘩する人っていうのは
学校に行っても喧嘩する
会社に行ったっても喧嘩する
政治家になったっても喧嘩する人
政党決める時でもよく喧嘩できる政党というふうになっちゃうんです
それは心に組み込まれています
で 智慧でその両方を管理です
立石 できます 例えばお腹が空いて食べたい
食べたいというふうな気持ちは
それは物理的なもので
体に組み込まれているものなんですけど
でも ちゃんと心を落ち着めて
そんな欲をいくら感じていると
そんなにパクパク食うだけの人生っていうのはかなり管理できます
で いろんなことさえ 体のことも全てできませんですけど
結構悪い方向へ行くことだけは避けるということはできます
心のものっていうのはもっとちょっとタチが悪いんですけど
心の癖っていうのはね
で それはもう当然もう瞑想させているのは
そのオートパイロットモードを壊して
瞬間瞬間新たに物事を見るという能力をつけてもらうためなんです
だから 決まってるパターンで見るということは
オートパイロット 例えば習慣
固定概念などなどで世の中を見るということは
心もオートパイロットモードなんですね
だから ものは馬鹿げて面白く見る人がいつでもその目で見ちゃう
批判的な目で見る人は
何でも批判的な目で見る
私には自信がないと心に刷り込まれた人は
いつでも自信がない どうしようもできないという
その目で何でも見る 私は自信がある
何でもできるぞという人は
いつでもその目でものを見る
どちらも悪いんですよ
自信がある できるぞと思っていてもできるわけないんだから
できるものもできないものもいくらでもありますからね
自信がない できないと思ったっても
できることは必ずあるしね
だからそういう固定概念
習慣というのは心のオートパイロットモードなんです
いくら言っても言っても
教えても教えても頭が全く変わらないとかね
なぜ変わらないかは 自分の前もったプログラムで全部処理しちゃうんです
ですから この固定概念は危険ということだね
固定概念の完全にはなくなりませんだからちゃんと観察能力で固定概念を潰して潰して
そのままないということで捨ててしまえば
その心のオートパイロットモードは綺麗に消える
それは消えない限りは悟りはありえない
輪廻の苦しみは消えません
あのプログラムで人を好きになると次のことをやる
人を好きになると次の人をやるという心のプログラムがあります
ご飯食べて終わったら
じゃあでは座るそうではテレビ見るそう
それはじゃあでは寝るそうでは起きるそう
では顔を洗うそうとかね
ではご飯食べるそう では出かけるそうとか
そうやって心っていうのは次から次へ一つ終わると次に何するかっていうこと
それで心が終わるんですね
だからストップしません
だから その機能がある限りは輪廻はします
死んでもまた機能 その処理の瞬間でも機能スタートするんです
だから苦しみっていうのは終わらないんですよ
同じところを循環している
だからそれを密教で消してみなさいと
習慣を消してみなさい
固定概念を消してみなさいと
それで心のオートパイロットモードが消えます
循環消えます 輪廻消えると循環は消えるんです